it's kind of hard to discern personally
yeah as to the differences in that
especially in like the passion making
segment of things
um but like I've met plenty of women
that smell like
welcome to another episode of trash
taste gonna drink some wine today God's
brought two bottles um
you're gonna drink some Yukon I'm gonna
drink my UConn super super it's been a
while since we drunk on the podcast just
chilled out with some drinks so I'm like
hey let's go let's warm myself first
because wow that's great excuse me you
know okay I don't know if this is just a
me thing but I really like I really like
the taste of Uconn
uh you know messed up episode of trash
days yeah
I think we're getting that drunk I can't
get drunk of two bottles of wine uh we
don't think we have three bottles
actually we've got three yeah we I we
had like uh so I bought two wines for my
collection uh because I just have my
collection too much another level here's
the problem every time uh we haven't
done this for a while but every time
we've invited people over people just
bring over bottles of wine yeah and they
bring over bosses of wine faster than I
can drink it so I've just been like
accumulating how often are you drinking
wine at home though like you and Sydney
not too often whenever we have a day and
we go out and we have a nice meal well
let's uh let's share our bottle when we
get home and then yeah so we don't drink
too often
um maybe we might you go home after the
meal yeah I always stay out it depends
let's go for more drinks depends depends
on the vibe sometimes sometimes I like
how we like having a nice meal and then
just chilling out and uh just you know
watching a movie or something like that
and just having like a nice end date uh
it's just not my friends of houses that
you want to go except for your house
my living room's a mess yeah yeah it
looks like a crane game Shrine
basically because it is yeah there's a
set of roman armor in my living room
what yeah don't worry about it okay I'm
not gonna ask you when you get up to on
your weekend well you know I laugh okay
I laugh is the Romans all right by
yourself in the living room by myself in
the living room and there's a treadmill
this is actually this is yeah I kind of
like I'm feeling the uh drawbacks of
living on the ground floor in a house
now
holy [__] [__] uh I've just been
having to deal with like cockroaches
recently you know do you know what I'm
like starting to think um
I have to clean your house no no no my
house is actually like genuinely pretty
clean because uh they we found out where
they're coming from and that's just like
the drains because it's summer right now
and every time we see a cockroach it's
basically like they're like tiny tiny
cockroaches they're not like the Giga
Chad cockroach you're getting like uh
Australia or in Thailand so I'm like
before if I heard cockroach I'd be like
[__] terrified but now I see the one
the tiny ones in Japan I'm like you're a
little baby but before it was a Dark
Souls boss yeah and now it's like a
tutorial now it's just like a slight
annoyance because I see I see them like
sometimes uh in the bathroom when I'm
just going and I'm like for [__] sake
stop crawling out of the drains police
is it just me or do I feel like do you
feel more I guess scared or in danger
when a cockroach appears in like
somewhere like a bathroom drain or like
say when you're showering for example
and it appears in the bathroom as
opposed to anywhere else I don't know
why I feel more vulnerable because I'm
naked no I like it more I I like it more
I can send them back to where the [__]
they came I like it more because one I
don't have to worry about making a mess
because I can just clean that [__] up
right away yeah if you're gonna murder
someone yeah you're doing the bathroom
yeah the tiles yeah yeah sure number two
well I mean you know from experience no
I'm just I I imagine that killing
someone then if you killed them and then
there was carpet everywhere you'd be
like oh for [__] sake my house doesn't
have carpets yeah yeah but like I most
most new house clean yeah and uh yeah
number two I like the fact that it's
like in the bathroom because I know
where I came from if it was in the
kitchen or the living room I'm like how
the [__] did you get in where the f are
you do you have friends do you have
friends do you have friends they're
chilling The Wine Cellar gone yeah it
sure has this marvelous God I'm glad I
stumbled in here
what I've realized every time I see you
like it's only happened twice by the way
this year
um
what like what I've realized is that if
I see one I cannot let that [__] out
of my sight I don't know why but this
one can't [__] like run off yeah okay
so like you need something together with
I'm not metal enough to like [__] use
my hand or whatever just yet I'm not
that Australian right right you're not
my time now right I try and get a ticket
I'll go for the foot though yeah but the
first like the first time this happens I
don't want to touch with my hands but
I'll crush with my feet but then it'll
be on your socks yeah it'll be on your
socks yeah but I don't want one I'm
watching them anyway
same thing with your hand I'll wash it
anyway
yeah I guess so I mean I wouldn't be
against crushing with my hands right
yeah it depends well because I already
annoyed one time I bought that cockroach
killer that's everywhere in Japan and in
that fridge yeah this [__] just tanked
it yeah I felt like he was like Kirito
in that one scene where he's getting
slashed I just felt like he was regening
quicker than I was
concrete I was doing damage over time
attacks and he was just like my regen is
greater you are nothing to me but then
if I went like he'd be dead yeah yeah uh
and so I was you know I think seeing
that site where he just tanked he didn't
even move that's what pissed me off yeah
he didn't even like care to try and
Dodge it like he was so impervious to it
that he was like and what what are you
going to do okay
yeah so I was like well [__] I'll
slap him so I did I tried to stomp on
him uh but I missed they're [__] fast
[__] yeah they are false little
antennas tell them when the foot's
coming yeah I always wondered did they
see life in slow-mo they must do they
must right yeah
like instincts like anime characters
whether you're like teleport behind like
I could sense your presence teleports
behind you nothing personal I feel like
they know when you're looking at them as
well because this has happened like
every time I've seen one I have looked
at it I'm like oh there's a cockroach
that has approached my field of view and
I stare at it I'm like you're not going
anywhere you're not going anywhere and
it's like totally still okay I'm like it
turns into a DBZ fight yeah yeah and I'm
like okay I know the tissue's there I'm
gonna look away for a second and you're
still gonna be there
it's gone like it just like they're like
the Weeping Angels
because then flies right I don't know
how flies can do it I forgot how they
can do it but they can sense the
difference in air pressure yeah so when
something's approaching the air pressure
they I obviously it's so small that you
can feel the air pressure yeah
um so I imagine maybe it's something
like that I don't know it must be what's
up okay question
would you
would you would you get all of the
benefits of antennas oh but you had to
be a normal person with antennas
you could you could literally get all
the benefits of having contenders but
you just have antennas what's the
benefits yeah what are the benefits
sensing the presence of someone coming
insane yeah air pressure differentials I
think that would just [__] me up because
I wouldn't really know you'd adjust
because you'd be born with it you
wouldn't just have it but I'd also just
be like [__] when I want a plane uh
yeah like I'd get on just be like oh
like I already suffered with the ear
popping and then I have to deal with the
antenna just be like I'm not sure I'm
sure if a cockroach got on the plane
it'd survive it'd be all right well yeah
those things will survive anything so
the point is would you okay what would
you be willing what deformity would you
be willing to accept
of like a of would you take wings and
hoppy uh no no because because if you
think about it Wings in human society
would suck to have ever yeah it would
also like how it's gonna fit in I'm sure
you can fly but yeah you've got to fit
in but it's not worth flying you know
like you know you could just [__]
build a device to fly better than you
know you still wouldn't I when I when I
say fly you're not suddenly impervious
to like pressure differentials of yeah
it'd be like a few hundred meters in the
sky yeah exactly I feel like flying such
a [__] overpowered no no over like uh
overvalued overvalued over I've become
obsessed with the idea of having
superpowers with severe drawbacks
so you can have something but you get
[__] why I don't know I think it's fun
it's fun hypothetical it's like you get
wings but you also have gonorrhea like
will you take it
like you're at the massive you're the
the biggest dick ever but you can't have
sex
yeah you just can't get all right just
having the biggest dick ever would be
its own Nerf because
yeah that's true that's a good point
okay what about
um this is just like a you were able to
yeah you were able to photosynthesize
but you would you would have a lingering
sense of hunger but you weren't allowed
to eat
why would I want to be able to
photosynthesize [__] love food why
would you pay for it huh yeah but it's
worth it yeah but that's that's worth it
like if I could you like the burden of
paying if I would put photosynthesized
then I would get fat on sunlight and I
don't want to do that I guess I can't
get that you can't get fat obviously you
know what I mean it's hugely obese dude
he's just like God I'm so hungry I'm so
hungry dude yeah just like you go you go
on like a beach holiday for one okay
like one week and you're like [__] oh
I didn't even [__] eat any drink any
cocktails you can get invisible but you
have to get blackout drunk this is
[__] to spin off to Darker Than Black
I've ever seen did you did you ever
watch Darkness yeah yeah yeah a number
of cigarettes containing nitroglycerine
already I mean none of these Powers I
actually want I don't want to be
invisible all right tell me a power you
want I'll tell your drawback okay
um I mean we've talked we've talked
about teleportation before you can
teleport so you can tell them all but
you have no way but you [__] yourself
every time I actually was gonna do
something like that but honestly I think
you could you could easily plan around
that there's not there's not enough a
drawback you can teleport but every time
you teleport
someone
someone you've met in your life dies
oh so you could be you're risking like
how many people you met in your life
like well we kind of [__] Facebook
friends yeah literally like if you have
if you have met would be like you've
exchanged words with someone could be
someone you bumped into sorry on the
subway you've anyone you've encountered
you can see if if that is the drawback
then once I am aware of that like
drawback I would just go out into public
and start talking to everyone yeah you
would yeah yeah but it would be like
you'd still have that lingering chance
that could be a close friend and if you
teleported would you do it would you
take it no no yeah you would no I mean
despite the ethical
um choice of killing a human life every
time you wouldn't know they wouldn't
know you'd never be found guilty
obviously that doesn't help yet
you would never you would never be
healthy you would never be held console
like held accountable for this I mean
are we ignoring the fact that you would
be killing someone every time you could
also die too yeah why can you meet
yourself yeah
really yeah damn sociopath I mean I
would use it for emergencies like let's
say oh yeah no of course it's like crazy
happened you're like no you say that but
you're probably gonna get to the point
where you're like [__] I need to go to
the company
she's like it still worried someone just
died yeah oh this is my flight got
canceled it's an emergency I don't
understand I really needed to go to the
toilet I'm sorry okay okay it would
start off as like a pure like life or
death situation and then in about like I
was gonna say five years but I've just I
think more accurately like five months
for you okay it will get to the point
where you're going to the toilet using
teleportation
hello guys I gotta be back all right Joe
give me a I'll give you a drawback well
what power do you want uh oh I like
teleportation but I want to hear your
power I'll make a drawback ah my power
give it to my power
reading Minds maybe reading Minds I
wouldn't want that power reading minds
but every time you read a mind uh
you oh okay I was thinking like some way
of having a drawback where you get
[__] up by keep reading Minds yeah
just [__] with your head what about
what about the drawback of you can
delete mine okay you can read minds but
you it is hard for you sometimes to
distinguish which memories are yours and
which are theirs
I think that would just happen yeah that
sounds like schizophrenia you know
you're a developer every time you read a
mind you'd get you'd partially be
assisting your own schizophrenia yeah
yeah maybe not okay
how about my favorite type now useless
Powers with useless drawbacks okay okay
uh what if you will never ever spill a
drink ever again in your life
but you can never drink again but
you have to eat at least one Olive every
single day otherwise you lose the power
I'll take that uh and someone dies
and you have no legs
[Music]
olives from a specific Olive maker in
Italy yeah
do you have any olives from uh Jean
perion what if they just run what if
like the chain supply chain just runs
out why is there a strong zero who got
the strong zero why did we bring you on
the ball
you want to join in can I yeah come on
drink on the job why not
allow it black pepper
this is this is this is the golden chips
black pepper oh I do love black pepper
you want to level one okay okay I should
have had more than just a [__] salad
before drinking this wine man this is my
problem every time every time and after
every time I'm after dark you guys are
like oh we got a fat Curry and I'm like
I had a I had a salad today double wine
please
I don't need plates what are we in the
21st century give me another one what's
another power up you will be able to you
will enjoy all media
200 more than you currently do you'll
get that much like drawback and then
serotonin from it however
the one in five chance of constantly
spoiling it for your friends and you
can't help it I take that yeah
that's easy yeah I think people have
that superpower right now
that's actually exists that's just uh
your average [__] fan account that's
your average one piece yeah
holy [__] I used I forgot how much I did
not miss Stan accounts on Twitter until
like and like when a hot new Showdown is
yeah log on to Twitter and I see this
[__] Jujutsu guys and fan account and
there's like Gojo and the new guy in
like the like his friends yeah and then
the manga panel they're like really
close and in the anime they're like
two inches more further apart okay and
they're like I can't believe they've
done this they've ruined the show
they've ruined it and I'm like oh my God
I do not miss Stan accounts oh thank you
so okay here's one for you you can run
at the speed of sound
Sonic is like Sonic you can run at Sonic
Speed but you're a Sonic fan
but in order for you to run at Max Speed
you need to be constantly shooting
yourself
literally die from uh just nutrition
loss because you literally run out of
poop and then your body would not have
any poop left so it just like sucks yeah
so you have to like eat as you run to
maintain it
how would that work this is a superpower
that's very similar to real life okay
you will have unlimited money for you
your friends and your family and
everything but at least once a day you
have to complete a full report
Commission
um how detailed are we talking I think
very hard I need to find the clients I
think I don't just come to you I think
you just described everything
yeah that's just that's just a very porn
artist because yeah what knows how much
[__] money they make yeah exactly if
you could uh
what about time travel would you would
you time travel
what would there be side effects whether
it's gonna be side effects what limit
are you willing to go to to time travel
what do you mean like what what am I
watching
oh yeah okay what have you time travel
but every time you time travel you're
gonna kill 10 people while you travel to
well I mean if I time travel away then
I'll be out of the jurisdiction you
can't go back until you kill 10 people
yeah so kill 10 people and then just be
like you got to kill them it's fine
and then you're gonna kill this one kid
I'm traveling to the past of time
traveling to the future we can't time
travel to the Future yeah travel really
fast yeah no one's done it yet though
okay technically people have so but what
I'm saying is like yeah but like that's
like [__] not that many years I'm
talking like no no it's not like it's
like a microsecond yeah exactly exactly
it's like the future yeah I'm talking
like you know several decades worth
maybe even more several centuries if you
want several Millennia yeah if you had
to pick if there were two buttons right
in front of you one of them you could
travel to any time in the past travel
back
no
well you you'll be taking a massive risk
traveling to the Future because you're
like what if you hate it
no one's gonna do it no what if you
could come back and you can only do this
trip once which one would you go to the
future will pass
I go to the Past yeah bro I just feel
like you'd be so goaded with all the
knowledge it'd be too op yeah in the
past yeah I would go to the future why
because then I'd come back and I'll be
like well I know what's going to happen
as if you survive you don't know what to
wait for you yeah
or if it's a brown waistline and no
oxygen well then I'll [__] enjoy my
life while I have it what if you're dead
right away yeah yeah what if you what if
everyone's using like [__] Elon coins
and shoving Jeff Bezos butt plug then
I'll just kill myself
this is not a future worth living for
because I thought about this I'm like
okay
if time travel did exist right
then surely
time travel tourism would exist right
because I I feel like I feel like time
travel museums huh
okay but like there are museums that's
museums and watching sci-fi films yeah
yeah but if you could
if you could visit any time period as
like a kind of kind of like a kind of
like a tourist where you you know
instead of going to [__] Japan on
your holiday you go to uh [__] 1980s
Japan yeah 1970 Japan or whatever which
time period would you want to see and
would you want to see dinosaurs no I
think that's overrated I would not want
to see dinosaurs because I would not
survive
um
in the past I would probably go back to
like
maybe like the Edo period
hello period yeah I think that'd be that
could be pretty dope like obviously be
dangerous as [__] any obviously any
period of history is way more dangerous
than right now but
I don't know I think it'd just be like
really cool to be like holy [__] that's
a real Sam
that's sick and then and then I get
caught
because I go back
and I'd be like hey
where's the guy who discovered lead
he'll tell me I'll shoot I'll shoot that
guy and I'll come back what do you mean
the guy decided to put lead in
everything and like poisoned everyone
yeah I'd be like Oppenheimer Mercy
I'll take him out before they make a
move no but like as a tourist you're
like not allowed to like interact
interact with things yeah I'd say like
error period yeah because I think it's
like it's it's far back enough where
it'll be obviously completely different
world but it'll also be modern enough
where you could get by
hopefully like inconspicuously or at
least more inconspicuous than say if you
went back to like you know the ancient
Egyptians or the Romans or whatever I
want to watch Olympics number one
the first Olympics
we somehow have it on DVD Olympics
let's see a [__] gladiator fight it's
like 40p think about think about back in
the day they didn't have [__]
television all they had was this one
event to like keep them entertained that
you could let you have to physically go
there so you have to physically go there
and that was like so watch a man get
slaughtered yeah for sport or about time
travel you can do it at a world but you
have to you have to call a coin toss
every time and what's the coin toss
entail that's just fear and hunger yeah
but you die
you die you die that is just fear and
hunger yeah but uh there's odds of that
no I definitely would not
time traveling worth it
well if your life sucks
well then I guess it is worth it all
right my life's pretty alright so I'll
pause yeah
what about if you have a power but you
spawned that monster from it follows
have you seen it follows no
okay so the the whole concept of it
follows right is that there is this kind
of like creature or Monster
if it touches you yeah you're dead Okay
but it moves really really slowly okay
and I can take the form of like any kind
of human being so you don't know
[Laughter]
you've had one glass of wine calm down
laughs
it follows if it was Jeffrey FC I'd be
[__] terrible
you know it's coming then oh God here he
comes help
[Music]
okay
I'm related to that okay what have you
time traveled every time travel usually
you you become a year younger
that'd be awesome I could be like 20
again yeah but then once you get a 20
can you do it once a year
so I will I will happily that that means
technically you can just be immortal
right yeah because you can just like you
you but you celebrate your birthday
can't return to the time that you've
been to
yeah you just live it again right yeah
but no you're gonna be you're gonna be
unhappy you're gonna be [__] living
Forever at some point you want to die
yeah you're going to want to get old at
some point yeah yeah I mean I mean some
people don't yeah I mean some people
want to be young forever
yeah I mean what you're describing is
basically just time traveling back to
reliving or you've already lived and I'm
like yeah that's that's awesome which
means I can go back and relive some of
my coolest memories
uh the kind of offshoes that is that I
would just have to relive a portion of
your life everything that you've already
lived and that's great because I can
just min max it what if you
uh what if you then when you go back and
you lose that year you also lose all
memories of that year that you lost
so you can get younger but you lose all
the memories of every year that you've
get taken back essentially then so you
could be stuck in this Loop of being
like why the [__] am I where am I then I
would take it because you would never
know
you
just described reincarnation
no I didn't yeah you go back to a time
like you go back to when you're born
again but you have no memories you can
do that too but you might get to age
seven and be like what the [__]
happening I don't even know you might
even forget you have the ability
but like yeah oh my God there's a trash
taste after one glass of wine if you
don't remember it does it even matter
because your Consciousness can't
register it so if you are never aware
does it really matter you're in a loop
it's just that's that's just it you know
okay yeah
I don't know why I love hearing I love
thinking about these stupid drop I have
another question about superpowers no
one's talking about the drawbacks super
powers obviously shows about Superman
Yeti I I want to know that like
Superman's scrotum increases by five
percent every time we use a laser beam
you know what I mean like that he's got
to be careful about it you know what I
mean like I want to know real [__] I
want to get to like a latest Superman
movie where he's like trying to [__]
destroy whatever and he's like oh [__]
and he loses balance because of his
giant nuts yeah like I that would be fun
to watch yeah this round would look like
a hobo if he existed in real life okay
think about
think about this how can he shave
uh yeah I guess you can't yeah yeah he
can't shave how would he actually be
swole how can he find any resistance
like work out with to have the physical
I saw this online one time's almost
saying this yeah
I'm I'm like Superman would be a scrawny
ass dude he can't cut his hair yeah I
could say they'll write a post for this
already like like old mine right sorry
like all my like all my old mine he's
like shriveled up oh yeah he would be
absolutely yeah ah but he would still be
all to power all like super super
powerful but he just look like a scrawny
dude
um I already think my super bowls are
like overrated okay if you even think
about it for like a second you can watch
you can watch a show and get all the
feelings of watching a show instantly
whenever you want to like whenever you
talk about something you'll be like I
want to watch Arcane which you never
would be like I can just watch it in an
instant yeah
but there's a one in five chance
what what's the one in five chance
there's a one in five chance that you'll
you'll net you'll just forget a piece of
media that you've already watched and
you can never watch it ever again
I'll take it yeah I'll take it but you
you could be like yes you can instantly
watch something you could instantly
watch something like I said you could
keep gaming it and keep doing it over
here yeah if you instantly watch so when
you instantly watch something all the
experiences I don't want to instantly
watch something why would I want to do
that your job would be like so much
easier yeah no I mean it would be easier
for my job but my but like to your to
your yourself it you'd be just as you
experienced it like you would have those
memories so basically time stands still
yeah while you watch it and you'll watch
it all but you occasionally will just
forget shows and you can I I would
rather have the ability to that just
happens to me
yeah
I'm like wait what was that show that
show about again that's just that's just
me with this guy I watched one is the
guy I forget one one yeah there's a
limit to how much ethical you can have
in your mouth I would rather
have the ability to erase the memory of
watching a show for the first time
I I think what's a drawback what's the
drawback you [__] yourself you forget
you develop dementia
drawback is let me let me let me think
of a drawback the drawback of your TV
screen gets two inches smaller
Death Note again but your TV gets
Smalling like [__] I gotta buy a new TV
again at some point we [__] reset it
I think that's perfect that's the level
that's the level of inconvenience I want
right where I buy this amazing TV I
really want to re-watch Breaking Bad oh
and I do it and then my TV suddenly is
smaller I'm like [__] I got a power up
that I actually want what is to be
fluent in every language
what's the drawback
the drawback
is that
you have komisan level communication
would you take it
you just learn more against all
introverts
it's better to be extroverted in my
opinion in one language than to be
introverted in like 900. oh there you go
we figure I mean there's been there's so
many benefits I mean you could still do
twins that you like I mean I've I think
we all value uh you know actually
talking and yeah but some people might
value just being able to read other you
know because if you can read every
single book ever yeah that's more
valuable but I think uh that's why it's
a good caveat some people take it some
people won't I think you'd be dumb not
to take it because you can be you can
learn how to be extroverted yeah and I
think I'd be actually I'd be like the
guy who knows all languages Rosetta
Stone Child's Play I can read it in one
moment
what about if you can understand all
languages and you forget one a day
[Music]
It's 190 something and you just like
well it might not understand a single
day one you might forget like some
absolutely ancient language that no
one's right off yeah yeah but day four I
forget English
and you're like well [__] at least I got
Spanish Chinese but no no day 90. you're
lost though but don't worry you still
have Aztec you know what I mean what's
the what's the conclusion to this though
is that you just your your debt your
debt you don't you can't you just
because you die yeah yeah you have like
the best five years of your life
probably I don't know how many languages
I've ever
how many languages exist oh God how many
ones you've ever
how many languages have ever existed
probably thousands all right Thirty One
Thousand Thirty One Thousand I mean
[__] great office yeah 31 000 Days to
Live you know you know that's that's a
lot no that's more than enough yeah yeah
yeah yeah wait how many days are in a
life
how many days how many days are in a
life in a lifetime lifestyle I think
that's actually a fantastic trade-off
yeah you know every single language
just pray to the gacha gods you don't
forget the ones that are relevant it's
just the awkward moment of when like you
know you start bragging to your friends
being like yeah I know Aztec and then
they come back to the next day being
like so what was I thinking about like
[__] I don't remember yeah you'd be able
to help solve so many you couldn't
destroyed to [__] oh no you talk
about getting Aztec yeah or forgetting
any language right wait how many days
yeah you'd have more than you'd have
more than enough however I want a
hundred languages of relevant nowadays
I know that's vastly under but let's be
like there's like a domain there's the
main like 20 that are the most widely
spoken and I guess if you forgot like
the the really big ones but can you
relearn languages no
you cannot relearn I mean you can take
this I would still take it I think it's
a great I think the odds are still on
your side you just pray that you don't
get a bad roll yeah like I just hope I'm
not on my deathbed and my like
grandchildren are trying to talk to me
and I can only reply back in Mesopotamia
you still have the same level of
intelligence though as well so like for
the first 12 years of your life you're
still [__] useless so you're just
burning languages away yeah uh you know
you've already lost a good few thousand
by the time you're able to use them sure
which sucks you're like do you guys know
Latin
Welsh no okay
uh yeah I think that'd be cool that'd be
a cool movie yeah
because it just sounds like a horrible
movie The Twist is they're all the same
language it was in his happier inside
they're living in a future world where
everyone speaks English yeah this
episode is sponsored by Harrys guys
we're on tour right now but we need to
keep up with our skin care routine I
really wish we had a great razor that I
could use to clear myself off whether
your ritual is minimal or elevated level
up your shave game with Harry's sleekest
razor yet the craft handle the
Innovative design delivers the same gray
shave you expect with German engineered
blades that Glide across your skin
experience the latest and greatest in
Harry's razor line I've delivered
straight to your door for just ten
dollars at harrys.com trash taste I
don't use any other razor I never should
say honestly I found Harry's I haven't
needed to use any other razor because
it's so goddamn good and look how clean
he looks as well that's what you can get
and guys with Harry's it is a premium
shave for Less you can experience
Harry's sleekest handle yet with their
crown soft handle starter set for just
get this ten dollars and they're still
offering a no risk trial don't like your
shade no worries it's on them so elevate
your shave to the latest and greatest in
Harry's razor handle lineup today get
your 17 craft handle starter set for
just ten dollars at harrys.com trash
taste that's harrys.com trash taste
thank you very much to Harris for
sponsoring us today back to the episode
do you know a video that [__] me up
the other day um I saw a video
where like it was an interview
apparently this is a lot of people have
this uh with someone who doesn't have an
internal monologue oh yeah I've heard of
this yeah I [__] wish I could turn
mine off I never [__] shut the [__]
up like I cannot comprehend how your
mind functions yeah without like an
inner voice yeah so like if you're
sitting there not talking to anyone are
you just in complete silence
just
making this [__] out
conspiracy it's gonna be there's gotta
be some people making the [__] up what
if what if they do actually have an in a
voice but it's just real like the
volumes down to like one and they just
can't hear
that's not yeah I mean I mean I don't
know my [__] monologue doesn't have a
volume you never know
apparently some people don't have one
which is even weirder in my opinion yeah
I got like they were talking about
reading right they were talking about
how they read stuff yeah and I was they
were like I saw this video and it was
like they were explaining that they
recognized the shape of the world I do
that uh and then with the shape of the
words there's a certain flow to the
shape that they recognize and they
internalize and [__] like that I do that
you do that yeah
no I do I don't read the words I read
the shape yeah but do you hear the words
when you read like when you read
something he [__] hears the word I do
what the [__] you don't hear you don't
hear what if I'm looking at this right
I'm looking at this I'm not I'm not
saying it out loud but in my head I'm
saying out loud strong zero uh
I mean I guess sometimes I would but not
all the time I mean now that I'm now
you're telling me to do it I'm doing it
I don't think I would normally do that I
think I would just clock it as strong
zero but I wouldn't say it in my head
you can't hear it but when you're like
reading a sentence like when are you
like let's say you're reading the
shittiest YouTube comments oh yeah yeah
I'll read it out of my head okay
oh yeah here's another question when
you're reading a really stupid YouTube
comment or a really stupid tweet do you
have like a voice in your head that like
reads it helpful hell yeah or do you
read out the sentence and then you find
it funny let's just read it my own voice
no I read it I read in a dumb voice yeah
like this video was so stupid I hated it
unsubscribed just like I think with some
of these these things right like yeah
yeah like people will they get they're
like I they go on forums like I saw this
this video game one time and and this
happened can you guys help me find it
and then it turns out it never existed
yeah but everyone's like oh I know that
game I think this [__] happens
yeah uh no it's different that's
different that's why people misremember
something oh yeah yeah
um but like they actually just everyone
just fabricates a game and they all kind
of have very uh sparse memories and
experiences I think this is what happens
sometimes with this stuff I think people
hear pieces of something they're like oh
I have that too and obviously there's no
way we can scientifically prove or be
like yes you have it or not we're just
going on the word of people you know
saying it yeah and let's be honest
someone found out they get a little bit
of attention for making something up I
think some people would do it let's be
real let's be real come on you know
people make [__] up let's not pretend
that we don't live in a world we don't
make [__] up uh for no reason like
there's people who are like oh yes my
body is a magnetic I live next to mine
it makes magnetic and they put like
spoons on their nose and they're like
what's wrong with you
this is not a me thing this is the thing
that people have do where they claim to
be magnetic and they just stick the
spoons and the forks on their body [__]
are you talking about it sounds like the
weirdest Favorite Dream Of My Life I
genuinely can't believe you've never
heard it no because that's so easy to
disprove yeah people are dumb as [__]
bro this is so common I can't I can't
believe you I genuinely am in shock
you've never heard of you fall into this
Rabbit Hole this has been on like
mainstream TV for like 20 or 30 years
I've never heard of this this is so like
people fake it all the [__] time I
think people fake it all the [__]
time but like you know it's always a
decency to like fake something that is
either really difficult to prove or just
straight up impossible maybe they just
want attention people want attention
they make [__] up all the time oh yeah
of course there's no difference between
somebody's faking and someone who
genuinely believes it I'm just dumb
uh I believe it's the same thing
no no no no no no I don't know what to
tell you man most people do like
performances or shows like look I'll
stick things to my body it turns out I'm
just sweaty it's like no there's
double-sided tape on this thing yeah
[__] in it it's [__] awful I mean
that it's a difference between like a
scam and someone who uh you know is
really believing in what they are doing
but is yeah scientifically wrong yeah
well you know it's like flat earthers
actually believe it yeah they do 100
they do
I'd like to hope not I absolutely do you
know I've seen
they absolutely do right so yeah it's
not like a nefarious kind of like
uh strong people it's not as well
there's some smart people who believe in
that [__] and it's like sad because it's
like they just get in this mindset and
then you know we're really bad at being
when we believe something being proven
otherwise yeah just as humans in general
no yeah so I think there's just a lot of
that at play and it sucks because again
you see some of these like really smart
dudes who are really put together who
are like I'm gonna disprove it and they
do a science experiment that proves that
the Earth is round obviously because it
[__] is yeah
um and it's like wow such a smart person
who could put together an experiment
that would actually prove if the Earth
was flat or not and they disproved
themselves and they still don't believe
it uh that's weird but also I don't know
I don't know the mental chemistry that's
going on there where you get faced with
evidence and you're like no
because if someone shows me that I'm
wrong and something like scientifically
I'd be like all right it happens all the
time like if someone shows me I'm like
food poisoning is really an illness
that happens all the time and trash
teeth you tell me Pete's across the good
I'm like no you're wrong and like that's
like my truth well that's subjective
yeah it's crazy to me that like yeah I
don't know it's crazy to me that like I
guess we talked we talked a bit about it
and other stuff like people I believe
historical events didn't happen it's
like we have so much proof it's like you
think someone faked it bro okay I don't
know that's weird well
if what if the evidence it's fake which
it sometimes is you know there's a great
uh we all know NASA fake the moon
there's a great Veritas video where
there have actually been many
conspiracies conspiracy theories that
would proven correct like we there are
situations where sometimes it is valid
to believe a conspiracy theory and then
that's part of the issue is that you can
never really rule stuff out yeah but
that's the problem it's like once one
conspiracy theory that has made its way
around the world has at the end of it
all proven to be true then that
validates every other conspiracy theory
to be like see this one was right and
that was that was labeled as a
conspiracy theory but which means that
our Theory which you guys call
conspiracy theories has a leg up in this
conversation because this one was proven
true when in real reality it's just one
anomaly also it's just nice just to let
your imagination run wild sometimes
sometimes reality is just boring and
it's just like no like a lot of the
times the boring explanation is the
right one maybe like I think it's yeah
it's satisfying to feel like you've
figured something out that not everyone
else did I was in an Uber in uh L.A
because of course
there's a guy and you know I
you know being a white guy I feel like I
attract the the crate like a lot of the
crazy like why where are you going with
this feel way more comfortable opening
up to me about the crazy and I also
don't judge because I'm like I actually
want to hear what they have to say yeah
yeah uh because I find it very amusing
yes so this guy starts going on about
something you know you say oh you're
from England that's nice it's nice he's
like yeah well
because I mentioned yeah England sorry
the UK so yeah he's in the UK oh that's
nice that's nice thing you know the us
is going to be a lot better when the
war's over I'm like I'm like yeah man I
guess the the whole Ukraine thing is
pretty pretty bad right now huh it's not
going too well he's like no no the war
happened in the US I was like this war
happen in the US he's like
well I don't want to get too much into
it because I don't know why you lie and
I'm like well I'm always interested to
learn and to be corrected
um because I just want to hear what he
has to say so I'm trying to like tell
them that you're entertaining him yeah
yeah man I I get you he's like well
he basically went on like the whole Nano
machines rant like Nano machine son
um instead of being like the inside
government yada yada and was like uh
tell me about it and he's like you know
I just
the global warming thing I think is just
a huge scam and I go well yeah but uh
why did you buy a Tesla then
he's like oh the pictures are just great
I was like yeah but I mean surely you
wouldn't get the electric and he's like
oh you know and I felt like I was losing
him so I was like yeah you're right
you're right you're right yeah but he's
just going off and on and on and on and
he seemed like a really nice guy
initially and like we're all put
together he started going off about
cabals in the government and I was like
just miseducated yeah what do you seemed
like a rather intelligent guy but he
kept going about vibrations and [__] and
I was like what happened to you
I I think the real problem is when
science became incomprehensible right
light light to the Layman well yeah like
the Hadron colliders you're too
complicated for the someone I understand
yeah that's scary you look at something
like uh let's say quantum theory yeah
you look at like string theory and
people yeah I don't know what the [__]
this is man really well I just need to
hire intellect so you need to watch a
lot of them I didn't watch Rick and
Morty so I don't properly understand but
you get into like quantum theory where
um you know it's you know they are doing
things with
stuff that's like my explanation of it
and the Hadron Collider is that your
explanation of course yes then doing
things with stuff okay okay explain to
me how this makes sense logically right
whatever the [__] uh the cat what the
uh
cat where something is both alive and
dead at the same time okay which is
quantum field Theory I can explain this
as someone who was this close to going
into quantum physics in uni okay and you
became a huge and then I became a
YouTuber I really feel
really fell off I nearly became an
award-winning artist I just didn't I I
became unemployed yeah so Schrodinger's
cat is this idea that the Universe and
every decision that is made in the
universe runs on what is called a system
yeah okay and please correct me in the
comments if I'm wrong about this but I
thought you're asking me I'm like
this is all you man but basically it's
basically it's like if a state of being
has two or more conclusions right which
say for example yes there is you know
this like cheese board for example has
the conclusion of being face up like
this or it has the option of being face
down like yes those are two different
states yes right but in reality what we
see is just one of those States this
thing is currently face down yeah right
Schrodinger's cat is this thought
experiment of there's a cat inside of a
box that is enclosed
um I think schroding originally did it
with like some chemicals Einstein did it
with a stick of dynamite but basically
[Laughter]
but basically there is a box that has a
cat and something or device that can
potentially kill the cat and they close
the box so they can't see inside the box
right there is a 50 chance that in
Einstein's case the dynamite will
explode and kill the cat or there is a
50 chance that the dynamite will not
explode and the cat is alive but because
the box is closed right now you don't
know what state the cat is in right both
States exist at the same time but
quantum physics state that this cat
right now is in a what is called a
superposition which is where it is both
alive and dead at the same time because
this system has not been closed we all
know so the closing of the system in
this case is when Schrodinger Einstein
opens the box to see if the cat is
either dead or alive not both
so now here's the question the question
is
what box is Schrodinger inside of that
made him close the system of opening the
box or closing it
Flat Earth in it
so there was this idea of well schroding
is like okay well I've determined my
actions have determined this system in
one way or another but what is
determining my system to be one way or
another what is what is what is creating
my reality
and that's the whole idea of Chinese cat
I think
I studied this I might be completely
wrong but that's my understanding of it
and it's very fascinating when you like
look into it because then you start to
look into multiple dimensions and string
theory and uncertainty principle and all
this kind of [__] yeah see like you've
you've already lost corner and like
partially me in that like conversation
so imagine like the average flat earther
yeah you know which you know have you
have you seen like the map like the Flat
Earth Map dude it looks badass
it looks like a Lord of the Rings Maps
yeah this is like token level of World
building man [__] you know man don't
write a book no one like like if you
haven't seen this map like flat authors
have made a map of like what is beyond
kind of like what we can see like yeah
there's like the end of the Earth like
what's beyond the end of the Earth right
and it is like some [__] Game of
Thrones level of World building it's
sick
yeah legit
the boys good together
well don't [__] with the Flat Earth you
don't [__] with the flat [__] with it
why why I just I just the thing for that
boggles my mind with the Flat Earth is
it like you could chose anything to get
invested in and the one thing you
decided to give a [__] about is
disputing that the Earth is a ball
like you could have gotten into like the
cia's pushing in our minds or something
which is kind of like wild but at least
out there yeah like you really chose the
most boring conspiracy theory of the
earth not only the most boring but the
most proven to be wrong yeah it's like
it's like uh it's like picking your
favorite TV show not like Rugrats it's
like really
is nobody's favorite show because that
uh about many shows that aired on like
Saturday night cards I'm gonna make you
both happy what
I'm waiting with one word PS2 demo discs
I never had a PS2 he he's a Nintendo I'm
a Nintendo boy bro he like
I never had a ps2.
first PlayStation console was a PSP I
just realized because I don't know why
the Flat Earth made me think about it
and Rugrats but I I played Joe goes home
and like worship is a [__] Kirby
Shrine and it's like Pikachu is your
parents should buy you games huh does
your parents buy you games when I was
little [__] they they would be like
Christmas is coming up you get one game
yeah no I was like that as well but I
[__] cherished that one yeah here's
the thing I'm the [__] idiot who'd
buy [__] straight to DVD games yeah I
didn't do that I'm a little kid right
straight to DVD so straight uh straight
to like you know the [__] back in the
day when a movie came out it had to have
a game come out with it oh I played the
Madagascar Xbox game though that was dog
[__] they're all dog [__] for like one
or two that ago The Incredibles game was
hype but I don't know oh yeah the
couple's game is good but I remember
like I had so many demo discs it came
with magazines I think I played the demo
disc more than I played anything else on
PS2 see I didn't get a shot I don't know
maybe it was just like they were too
damn cheap well no maybe you'll just my
area or maybe just Australia in general
but I never had like the the magazines
okay it's uh in the fridge sorry I I
interrupted how Dave sorry one's more
important okay yeah fair enough I never
had those like gaming magazines growing
up I didn't get them but my friends
would give me the demo dish when they
were done where did they get them from
the magazines the way they get the
magazines from they'd buy them from
where the store
see we didn't we didn't have that the
supermarket sold magazines we no we
didn't have those magazines that came
with those demo discs oh okay I I they
were definitely like UK exclusives yeah
because like obviously the Australia
must have had it you've probably had it
amazing though like yeah you know you'd
get like I remember I played the Ratchet
and Clank demo okay like 20 plus times
and I don't know I never played the game
but I played the robot battling thing on
the third Ratchet and Clank in the demo
I played them like a hundred times the
fact that you
I never could my parents never bought it
for me from that was me with the Metal
Gear Solid one demo you tell me this
yeah yeah it's I mean it was such a good
demo I never got the demos man I just
got the game
[Music]
it's a privilege for me to say bro like
why aren't we time traveling back to
this time yeah just [__] around and play
video games I just want to mind empty
just play some [__] Mario slogers
with my friends dude yeah
you bastard which marriage Cyrus which
console the GameCube one this is [__]
okay did you ever tell you about this
thing that happened to me with the
second game what second marriage slogers
they released yeah the newest one right
so they released it on the Wii
and I I was in my wee phase where I was
obsessed with pretty much any any
anything Mario I bought it oh hell yeah
because you just know it's gonna be
goaded hell yeah dude yeah that's a
great Mario games you know in all the
Mario games that I played up till then
that was sport had served me very well
mainly Mario super strikers
which I was so pissed off with my little
brother for because one day I came home
and he'd stabbed a hole in all of the
plastic of the front
just because he was bored I would kill
my brother if that and I realized that
like that game also when I was like 17
when I was selling all my games yeah to
buy new games that one resold for like
full price if it was like normal oh yeah
you [__] up the front and stabbed it
all so it was only worth like half and I
was frustrated because that was a lot of
money I mean you still got half for it
dude that game you at least in Europe it
was so hard to get a copy of it like oh
I guess yeah UK because like everyone
everyone just like that was like such a
sleeper hit anyway yeah that's such a
good game
um what were we talking about uh there's
Sluggers so for one Christmas the
Christmas prior remember I told the
story on trash days I'd gotten Pokemon
Emerald months early because we imported
it yeah like I don't know where got it
and I was like the coolest [__] kid
in school everyone's like how the [__]
does he have Pokemon Emerald three
months early it came out I was like
automated already beat the uh because
they had like the battle tower at that
point yeah already got everything done I
am and so I was like well I'll just do
it again with Super Mario Sluggers yeah
I'll get the game early and I'll I'll
[__] behind how did you get emerald
early
my mum ordered it from either America or
China oh okay all right because it comes
out afterwards because this is back in
the day where
um it was Japan America Europe Australia
yeah yeah and they really like Europe
normally
weirdly in some consoles they got
shafted and other consoles they got at
first it was so bizarre how I would end
up working yeah uh normally you could
count in Japan getting it first yes of
course so I might have got a Japanese
copy anyway that we had region block so
I got this disc didn't work on the way
obviously we didn't know how to region
blocks we would my parents don't know I
don't know I'm a dumb kid yeah
um and so we my mom had sent it back
this is my Christmas present the one I
was so so excited for and I went through
like a year of trying to get this game
back and forth and I just could not get
it and I think it just didn't release in
Europe in the end I think oh really it's
the baseball game the second one oh the
second one uh I don't know I never
played the second one I only played the
GameCube one all right my Sluggers so
many hours into that game holy [__] I
still have that I I still have a [__]
physical copy of GameCube Mario slogers
right that [__] in a party setting bro
that [__] goes hard that should go so
hard you don't even have to know
anything about baseball that game is so
fun I've never played Mario as well
because that was past my Nintendo phase
oh dude it's so good like my Nintendo
phase died with like the GameCube uh
that was like the last console that I
owned until the switch yeah you never
play Mario Galaxy yeah [__]
it was Mario Super Sluggers the game
that I was trying to get my goddamn
[__] hands on for ages yeah never
released in Europe or Australia really
we were both cocked wait what the [__]
because I called the sequel oh the
sequel okay it was never released in
Europe or Australia and I was trying for
like two years to get it uh just because
I thought it looked really cool yeah it
turns out the game was kind of meh
um but I was still like trying my
goddamn hardest to get it
um and yeah I was really sad about that
I still wake up a cold sweat sometimes
thing about I never got to play it you
have to play it yeah you're playing on
stream because I played like the I
played RollerCoaster Tycoon a [__] town
as a kid yeah same that was [__] that
was so coded yeah that game had no right
to be as good as it was but it was in
the book and it was so fleshed out so it
was it was so ahead of its time yeah and
then I played another version of a game
it was very similar on PS1 called just
theme park World okay the logo is ass
yeah I played it on stream one time I
was super nostalgic about it but holy
[__] is it hard to run PS1 games on an
emulator and find the copy that works
and yeah it was fun A lot of fun all
right you can't game for five years
what's the last game that you play
before you like game for five years just
just
like how long do I have yeah how long do
I have how long do you have with it it's
24 hours so you have 24 hours it's your
last day you can't even beat a [__]
RPG it's it's your last day it's your
last day before you can do everything
else you just can't play games
oh that's that means purple which is
this theme color yeah it's like uh
I know
uh [__] Pokemon hot gold
you could beat that in 24 hours and that
is okay if you say TFT I'm gonna I'm
gonna [__] slap you do it I'll kill
you do I have am I like are those 24
hours am I fully alert like normal or is
it like a normal sleep schedule like a
normal
sleep by 16 hours I'm cooked yeah so
tomorrow you wake up you have all day to
play this game and it's the last game I
have one day yeah yeah you have a full
waking day I would play hard gold bro
for five years five years yeah
honestly right in my head I play I play
TFT
go to my head
I guess so hyped to just squeeze in a
game some days when I have like maybe I
got like three meetings in a day you
wouldn't play Bloons Tower Defense oh
that's so good though as well I made my
own real life uh I think that moment
when I don't know if anyone like when
you have like three meetings lined up
yeah and you have like you have like 50
or 60 minutes and you like I squeeze a
game in and you do and it's like ah that
was fun because I never get time to play
it so whenever I get a chance to squeeze
one in I'm like yes that sounds like
every time we talk about balloon style
defense on this [__] podcast it just
makes me want to go home and just play
have you have you played it recently no
it is fun really it is I bet I enjoyed
the I watched the four how long was this
video I watched like a three hour
YouTube video from this guy explains me
and it was so [__] good the new
balloons is Goldies they update it so
much it's actually a great game this
episode is sponsored by code Geoff
solution the Rebellion lost stories
kokio solution of the Rebellion lost
stories is a free strategy game based on
the popular anime of the same name in an
alternate reality where the Britannia
has almost conquered the entire planet
each of the countries subjugated under
the Britannia rule have their freedom
rights and even their names taken away
in Area 11 a young man named Luke will
start his Rebellion on the day he meets
the mysterious C2 who grants him a
peculiar power the GEOS the story is
told from the point of view of the
Lucia's friend and offers a fresh take
on the anime narrative I mean I think we
can all agree Code Geass is an
absolutely goated everybody loves it and
you're not telling me I get to see my
boy Lelouch Callan C2 again absolutely
not only that God but all the original
voice actors are back for this game as
well isn't that insane are you telling
me the main story card scenes are
created in live 2D giving a beautiful
art style that mirrors the original
anime as well God damn right God not
only that the game features epic
gameplay in which you can have to take
command in fast-paced battles where
proper placement of your squad's
nightmare frames are the difference
between Victory and defeat high quality
3D battle scenes add even more
excitement to each Skirmish not only
that you can create your own unique
battle Squad all the characters and
Nightmare frames that appear in the
anime can be you used to create your own
unique Squad so what are you waiting for
download kogiosolution the Rebellion
lost stories now by clicking the first
link in the description box below or
scanning the QR code on screen and don't
forget to redeem our gift code trash
taste for some epic in-game get the
gifts smash that link in the description
to find out more back to the episode
yeah gone is doing like what my dad does
where now it's more oh [__] oh I'm
[__] by the end of this podcast this
wine is going to be up to the brim
sorry man I'm [__] shift it was a
cool memory for me drinking with your
dad and having the yeah
[Music]
buddy I've got I forgot what the
cocktail yeah cockatiel that was just
having this the coffee was chilling on
my shoulder for like two hours
he loved you I was like yes let's drink
wine there's like a pet shop like near
where we live that we have to walk past
uh every time we're like in the window
and like they have this whole section of
like birds I'm like I keep walking past
please join the bird Brigade birds are
the [__] best
and the more I go on the more I realize
how gooded they are yeah you know
everyone has a dog and a cat but you
know you don't have to take a bird out
for a walk they have a ton of
Personality yeah they do that's great
question yeah have you changed being a
dog or a cat person over time uh yeah
because I after I found it because he's
like yeah All-Star found out I was
allergic to cats I became a dog person
yeah but you still like cats I still
love cats right but that's good there is
the phys yeah it's really I've
flip-flopped between being also what are
you now I think I'm a dog person right
now dog person I think it matches my
energy of where I'm at in life yeah I
think for a good five years he's just
been hanging out with dieters a lot why
because he has like Labrador energy he
does he does he is a labrador dude he's
a he's a baby Labrador okay like I
always flip-flop between the two because
I like honestly perfect life I actually
won both I want a dog and a cat and a
bird
they can't live in harmony unless they
can depends on the breed they'll be up
to Shenanigans
one of them is dying yeah like I I don't
know I I just the more I end up I feel
like the happier I am the more I want a
dog yeah to match my level of
satisfaction in life and the cat is that
when I'm feeling down I'm like just
brood with me just sitting just just
chill just just sit in the corner while
I watch TV wait did you own any pets
growing up no never really no I don't
know why I think because we were always
surrounded by pets like all our friends
had pets you know because in Wales it's
so common to have a dog it's so easy to
have but also you you're like what a
family of like what three other brothers
yeah and I think we always ask for pets
but our mom was like are you gonna take
care of it because if you don't take
care of it no haven't it did you have
pet squirrel I did not have any pets I
had a goldfish I wanted a fair you might
as well
I think I like must have like inherited
something from my dad
because my dad told me once that my
dad's like always been like an Auntie
like kind of like animal pet person and
I thought he just [__] hated animals
for like the longest the longest time in
my life uh and then like I remember like
having a conversation with them one day
about like how he took care of a cat and
like you know yeah when the cat passed
away he was just like I would never love
an animal again you know that's like I I
I like that personally yeah I'm like
yeah I get it you lost a member of your
family and then you're like no I am not
ready for another one yeah and that's I
think that's like the philosophy I would
have because I don't know if I've told
this like this uh
not the birds uh yeah I don't I didn't
technically have pets growing up but I
had like
dot like family dogs in like Thailand uh
like around the neighborhood yeah yeah
like no like we uh so like my Thai home
we have like a [__] massive family
home a bunch of dogs there when I was
like [__] four years old we like
adopted some puppies uh they let me know
them and uh the names were Pepsi and
cola wow
and I will never forget Pepsi Cola uh
for the rest of my life and like every
time I'd come back to Thailand because I
come back to Thailand every year they'd
always remember me even if it's been
like a little bit longer since I've seen
them
um and basically we grew up at the same
time because I heard them when I was a
kid and I saw them grow up they were
good boys and then they were gone and
I'm like for the longest time I'm like I
don't even know that I I don't want
another pet I I totally feel that man
yeah I think so far I have lost
in my life
yeah sure excuse me because again like
my my family [__] especially my
parents [__] love animals so like at
every moment in my life there was at
least some kind of pet or animal yeah
just existing in my house like growing
up and yeah I mean it [__] sucks like
obviously losing a a pet that you've had
even if it's for a short amount of time
like you know
um it [__] sucks if it does feel like
a family death but like
I don't know it's uh it's always
rewarding to be able to like get to that
point where the you can feel that that
severely about it yeah exactly where you
can like you can be with this animal
yeah its entire lifetime and then for
you to be there when it passes like
that's a really special moment and like
it doesn't get any easier obviously but
like just give it a good life you get
yeah just the satisfaction of like this
animal probably thinking to itself like
thank you for giving me a good life like
it was fun I know just thinking about
this man it reminds me of all the pets I
had and it's [__] in net like the few
times I ever saw my dad cry was when our
pets died and I was like that [__]
hit me hard and like obviously the pet
dying was one thing but then seeing my
[__] parents cry like that [__] that
[__] broke my heart as a kid we need a
trash chased dog
if one of us had a dog no and we just
like hey do you mind if Steve comes to
the office today you'll be like okay
question okay question what's your dream
pet right now flip-flopping what's your
dream pet if you had to pick one pet to
have right now
what would it be I wish you had the
ashiba Inu with the energy of a golden
retriever
y probably uh that probably exists I
don't know they're like Shivers can be
quite energetic if they don't but I want
the love of a golden retriever well then
you best get a golden retriever they're
huge for Japan oh for Japan yeah what
would you get I'm gonna get a dog I'm
gonna get one I think I want a parakeet
right now parakeet I know I'm in like
the bird phase yeah
the dudes are the type of dudes who'd
make ancient Scrolls like 500 years ago
um that's more so with me because I want
to now you want an owl yeah you'll never
see it it's nocturnal no no no no it's
like if if it's if it's a raised like
hand raised then like they're more so
like fitted to like staying up a little
bit later than the usual sleep schedule
they're like the they're like the day to
sleep schedule the vowels all right like
that it's like pretty much the opposite
like so yeah no because like Japan is
one of the few countries in the world
where you can own a pet owl without any
necessary um documentation or like
licenses and Japan's really weird like
that ferrets are another one that you
can own here chinchillas you can only
you can own parrots in most countries
but with a license
I don't think so yeah mostly my friends
own ferrets really yeah or chinchillas I
know for a fact you can only own in
Japan I mean legally and chinchilla is a
[__] adorable as well Japan has a
really weird
outlook on animals like the reason I
said like no to like a trash cheese dog
is just because like to me a dog is like
a baby well I don't know what I mean by
trash taste dog is yeah I have the dog
I'm having the dog but would you if I
had a dog would you object to the dog
turning up every week can we just chill
with the dog no of course that'd be hype
as [__] what would you name your dog
oh man I don't know I
part of me wanted to do it like it's
like a monarch name just to kind of get
back at them just Charles
my favorite is when people give their
pets really human names or give it like
some kind of uh I don't know dude I I
thought I I really wanted to get a dog
and just yeah his full name would be ask
lad but he would be lad live or lad but
he but his ass
he's the goat he's the ghost I I had a
friend who had a dog uh it was like a
miniature schnauzer or something come
here boy I had a conversation with
Sydney we were talking about like yeah
what if we had a boy what would you name
it and Cindy was like oh I have some
names I like Kirito
and she was like oh yeah I really like
the name I actually really like the name
Johan or Griffith oh my father and I was
just like Sydney what the two evilest
[__] yeah what are you trying
to like
well what do you like trying to
cultivate here Sydney so I really like
the name Hitler
is a pretty cool name Johan you guys
there's a not a German enough as a
couple
can you imagine in like 10 years time oh
this is my son Johan manitartha
born you with like the whitest name in
existence so it's like oh this is
Malcolm
like that's hard like I what imagine
having a kid and having to name them
like that's so much mean
never owned a pet of course I'm of
course I'm drunk yes I have never
whatever I got [__] Pepsi Cola that's
probably my favorite drink when I was
[__] four years old yeah that's not
that bad when I was born we had little
guy in Pocky listen so it's not it's not
that much different it doesn't matter
because Joey's dad didn't even use his
real name half the time
yeah I mean that just seems like
obviously you know I'll get to that
bridge when I come to it uh but like
name me your kid that's like so much
pressure right because yeah you should
pick an easy name
what are you gonna call your son yeah
I'll figure it out I'd be like Steve or
something bro No One's Gonna Give A [__]
uh Beyond yeah
by the way congratulations to Fearless
for being a [__] Dad yeah
congratulations
why are we clapping he literally ensured
him
so when are you going in a relationship
you're in like a long-distance
relationship as well
okay I gotta ask
when you first met Aki right yeah
were you really worried about how she
smelled like before before
shut the [__] shut the [__] up okay okay
okay like what did you worry be like oh
I hope Sydney you're really Gonna Mail
in too much
okay okay this is like did you lick her
sweat this is like pre-mailing talk okay
right because I like I I had a genuine
worry I remember like I had this such a
core memory on the plane uh like meeting
Sydney for the first time okay obviously
we got on really well I love Sydney I
love her personality but I've never met
her in real life sure but we'd had like
video calls before sure right so but
like here's the thing
there are some senses that you can't get
Beyond like you know on a video call
yeah and I'm like I'm around this store
being like what if I don't like the way
she smells like
like that's that's a big thing that's a
big thing perfect personality perfect uh
we get along conversationally just kind
of smells like [__] you know uh deal
breaker smells like [__] perpetually I I
understand the thing of you gotta like
it whatever it is yeah I mean I mean no
okay I don't call a stink I call it musk
actually the musk okay like here's a
little strong musk I got a [__]
incredible mustard oh yeah you do like
like
Joe he's dying you're absolutely like
here's the thing right you I to me like
you need to like someone's natural smell
right yes because you're especially if
they're a partner you're gonna be
spending like so much [__] time with
them right yeah Febreze in it
as I may whatever he comes to bed hold
on there's just like just the breeze huh
yeah
it's like Sydney hold on
let me let me know hey it's gonna work
now I can kiss you okay okay it's good
because here's the thing okay like
okay especially with your life partner
you you to me you have to like pretty
much everything about them you know
um and like smell is uh heavily
important thing especially when it comes
to just like natural senses and stuff
like that you're going to be spending a
lot of time with them especially in like
especially moments and passion yeah of
course that's very very important if you
don't like someone's smell to me that is
like almost a deal breaker like I I have
I there's there have been points where
I've not been attracted to someone
purely because like they have natural
smell that I do not personally like well
considering I've only ever been with one
woman in my life his car it's kind of
what the [__] what the [__] okay
considering I've only ever been with one
woman in my life without being hockey
it's kind of hard to discern personally
yeah as to the differences in that
especially in like the passion making
segment of things
um but like I've met plenty of women
that smell like [__]
where I'm just like yeah that's kind of
a deal breaker even like
you're not like I'm not you're a lovely
person but I just wish you showered more
you know even like even been like
jacking off and then you farted and you
smell it and they just killed
I think you're like I don't want to be
anymore
I no longer wish to jack off I'm about
to Climax and then somewhere it smells
like [__] and I'm just like oh that just
kind of ruined my day no Connor I'm a
man of commitment no matter what I
follow through so the smell with the
ballad of Sydney is what I'm hearing
sorry the smell of Sydney wouldn't have
mattered is what you're saying no I'm
like oh
him and he would have thought it through
no okay so like I remember like I so
remember vividly the first time me
Sydney because I was like holy [__] no I
remember so vividly because I remember
being like I see Sydney I'm so [__]
happy I'm overwhelmed with positive
emotions that I finally get to meet her
in real life sure and then we hug and
then I'm like I'm so happy and then she
smells good and then and then like
literally like five seconds in I'm just
like all right all right that's [__]
all right thank God thank God that is
psychotic if I met up with a
long-distance person and I heard the
[__] audible sniff I'd be like
okay question real talk all right you
guys both had long distance
relationships yeah what was going
through your head on the way to meet
them
um I've never had that so I don't know
what it you know I don't know all I was
thinking of in my head was because you
met at ax I meant yeah weekend of as
that must have been more like a 15-hour
flight was going through your head uh in
my head I was just thinking like God
damn I always keep going through my head
okay
no it was only that I refused in my head
I was just like [__] I wish she smells
good
was it like I mean obviously okay in my
in my head legitimately I I think in my
head I was just thinking like I hope she
you know because like I've had before
you know I met Aki like IRL I had a lot
of like online online friends right and
so like I I was already used to kind of
having this like online relationship
with people you know that obviously that
being platonic other than Aki but you
know there are those moments where when
you pursue an online friendship and then
you meet them IRL and they're not quite
the same person yeah so in my head I
think legitimately I was thinking like I
hope she is as [__] cool as she is
online in real life and luckily she came
through and I was like okay thank God
she wasn't like faking that [__] were
you worried about how you were coming
off though as well oh absolutely yeah
absolutely how did you ensure that it
went smoothly oh I activated maximum
risk like I I I try to make sure like
everything I said and did like was like
[__] like yeah
like you know just kind of giving off
that like cool demeanor you know and
then when we started like actually
talking and then like eventually like
you know got together I was just like oh
none of that [__] [__] matters
because she just likes me for who I am
you know so like I don't have to like
fake being like cool or whatever because
again like you know I've only ever been
with one person in my life what's that
was hockey sir was that worries about
the online aspect of it and and a little
bit influencer was there ever
conversations about it a little bit Yeah
I think like it was kind of interesting
to kind of get to it was it was like
meeting a completely different person
again yeah you know and then falling in
love with them again like it was it was
like I know your online side of things
and I really like that side of things
and then meeting them IRL was kind of
like it was this is same same but
different you know like it was it was
kind of like oh I see new sides of you
that I never got to see during the whole
online thing
um and so now I'm glad to know that like
not only do not only did I get to see
those sides of her but I actually like
those sides of her and it's and it kind
of like you know made me realize like oh
yeah I think this relationship is worth
pursuing that's sweet and now we've been
together for seven years ask you more
questions in a second okay Joe I
actually because I've never asked you
this yeah how was the conversation about
uh deciding to go public with it what
was that conversation
you were not you it wasn't enough
it just felt like after I mean from my
perspective it was like we knew you were
dating and then suddenly it was just
public knowledge and everyone knew yeah
and I don't remember was there an
announcement video how did it all yeah
there was an announcement video how was
that like how did that all come around
so who brought it up originally we
decided that like okay for the first
maybe three or four months we would kind
of keep it private when did you decide
this was that like when we started going
out is online yeah so like who brought
this idea up uh I think Archie did okay
yeah so Aki was like Hey I want to like
make sure this is like you know legit
and we actually like like each other's
company regardless of the whole YouTube
thing
so let's like kind of keep it as private
as possible for the first maybe like
three or four months
um and I was like sure that makes sense
so you know I could like spend time with
her off camera you know actually like
Bond a proper relationship with her
right well regardless of the YouTube
videos and then obviously when she came
to visit me in Japan and when I would go
visit her in Vegas we would make videos
together and then it started to get and
less inconspicuous of like they might be
dating yeah
um and so I think the breaking point for
me especially was like the point where
it was like the worst kept secret of
like okay these guys are clearly like
together or you know at least in a very
intimate relationship together so I said
to Aki I was like hey it's been like you
know three or four months since we've
been together now
what do you think about going public
um and she was like At first she was
kind of like oh you know I want to give
it a little bit more time but I also
understand that like at this point we
might as well just get out of the way so
that we can just do whatever the [__] we
want so then we were like all right cool
so we went public we we each uploaded a
video I decided to do the videos so my
video was the announcement video of
saying like we're dating and then Aki's
video on her channel was the video
breaking down how it happened
now the question is who's gonna be part
one yeah is it me or you how was the
reaction initially to it because I I get
um any of this I remember I remember it
happening but I don't remember any of
the reactions I think it was pretty I
mean this is weird for me to say
personally but like I think it was like
pretty big especially in the attitude
Community because yeah it was kind of
the first time where two Anna tubers who
you know were fairly well known at the
time especially in the community kind of
decided to get together yeah
um like I'd other than Sydney and gone I
don't really know anything you guys came
into it no I mean like we won uh I mean
Sydney wasn't really making content we
were yeah I mean I think everyone knows
Sydney yeah if they're actually these
online presence has always been yeah
Sydney and also gone yeah yeah yeah and
it's just like I was at the time I you
know there was a long time where I
wasn't doing YouTube full time I did
YouTube full-time like three years after
no maybe less cycle yeah I think I think
the time that I think the time that we
announced our relationship publicly God
was still on his hiatus
like uh the reason when you announce it
that's the reason we became friends yeah
I I remember this vividly because I
remember we were alone with this yeah
this wasn't in the lore of episode one
oh no it's like like it's the fact okay
here's here's here's what I remember uh
because I think this was about the time
when I was like coming back to YouTube
actually because I remember being in
Thailand yeah uh and I remember like
coming back from this ax trip being like
Jerry's uh
uh
like Joey hates me I hate him we're just
not gonna get along who comes out to
dating hockey you hear the story about
long-distance relationship and I don't
know why you're just like oh he's a
human now
like oh we're Bros I get I get what he's
going through
he just like me for real I send Jerry a
message being like yo
congratulations man I get it in long
distance relationship and Joey replied
and I'm
made me realize
Joey's the real one maybe yeah you think
you're gonna hate the marriage turn out
to be the best friend no it was really
surprising because I remember when we
went public we got I I at least I got a
lot of like private DMS from like other
Anna tubers uh and messages from other
Anna tubers who I thought didn't know
who the [__] I was or cared who the [__]
I was but I feel that day it was so big
even comparatively to the scene it was
they all they all knew I guess so yeah
because like I had all these like you
know that's how I became close with guys
like chibi reviews because like I didn't
even know he knew who I was and they
sent me a DM being like yo congrats on
you being with Aki like that's [__]
cool and I'm like oh [__] I didn't even
know you knew who I was so it kind of
like weirdly validated me in that
community in the same way because I
always thought I was kind of like the
anomaly that just like popped up out of
nowhere and I thought like like gaunt
initially had I just thought everyone
[__] hated me all right so I never
like really even tried to interact with
the annotube community at that point but
then when I came out with Aki I was like
I realized I was like oh people in the
community actually won know who I am and
two actually care about who I am yeah
yeah and so that's that was kind of my
window to be like hey let me try and hit
up these other you know creators in the
NSU community and you know some of them
like gone and you know like some other
people I'm I'm still I still talk to
pretty regularly and I'm pretty close
with and we're in good terms and stuff
like that so I think all in all it was a
good decision to do
um it's interesting how it's changed
though like nowadays people don't make
those videos anymore and bring back any
cheap communities people please
guys but also people just don't make
videos about being like I'm in a
relationship no no I think it's creative
I mean not to say it wasn't a good idea
but I think it's the maturity levels of
YouTubers have kind of gone a bit better
now I think so I think the whole talking
about that stuff is kind of like it's
kind of yeah ladies and gentlemen stop
everything because this episode is
sponsored by vessi look at these pair of
vessels that me and gone are wearing
right look at this vessi gang rise up
right Connor let's go one time I'm not
wearing my vest
how dare you you betrayed the bestie
gang no episode of the year I'm wearing
besties you know why guys because
they're so comfortable waterproof
perfect for every single occasion and
their material is so breathable that
it's perfect in summer and winter it
feels like I'm wearing nothing at all
nothing at all nothing at all I've worn
my vessies in every single weather
Sunshine snow rain sleet you name it
vessies is perfect for any situation of
any day we just toured Europe and I only
packed one pair of shoes and those of my
vessies because I know they can handle
any situation this is so good I wore
them to God's wedding that's not a joke
I also wore them to my own wedding that
is also not a joke not only that vessies
has all sorts of different styles of
shoes as well sure the ones that me and
Garner wearing stylish as hell but if
you're not necessarily into these kinds
of shoes Bessie has an entire collection
of all sorts of different shoes
shoe it's a lifestyle guy absolutely so
don't waste any more time head on over
to vesi.com trash test and pick yourself
up a pair click on vessey.com trashchase
and gear up for your next adventure back
to the episode I don't know if this is a
me thing I'm going back to smell I'm
like maybe I have been talking to melee
for too [__] long uh you definitely
have yeah because like okay
you haven't you ever met like someone
who smells like your parents what the
[__] yeah it's like the lead soundtrack
well that's your biological thing that
we've been programmed to not yeah yeah
yeah because we don't want to inbreed
yeah yeah yeah so if you smell like
brownies you're like disgusted by it
yeah like I'm pretty sure there's like a
study that like your smell can tell how
close you are genetically to a person
because like the less I just crushed
this guy in chess
lesson comments you have with their
jeans the better they're gonna smell
right yeah
the million dollar question is does
Sydney smell good too Cindy smells great
which is great because that means great
because I mean this is gonna sound like
the most serial killer [__] talk
because that means genetically we we are
we are very genetically diverse but she
smells like apples
oh God you smell good God I gotta stop
doing the mailing
holy [__]
that's uh but that's that's like the
trouble of like long distance
relationship because I had like so many
anxieties obviously I was like very very
excited like me Sydney but like there
are this was like my very first
long-distance relationship so there were
just so many things that I was used to
in like a real like an in not a real
person like in uh like a close distance
relationship that I'm like there are so
many gaps in my knowledge that I would
feel very very comfortable about
approaching this wrong long distance
relationship I'm not I'm like
kind of just have to hope those gaps
that aren't filled are just like good
how how long were you in a long distance
with Sydney for
it was like a year or something oh
that's not even that bad yeah two and a
half years boy two and a half years how
did you do it man the way we did it was
we were both established YouTubers at
that point and so we could work from
anywhere so there would be moments where
I'm just like yeah I'll be in Vegas for
three months yeah sure I'll come and
live with you for three months and I did
that multiple times like I think over my
entire life I probably spent over a year
and a half of my life in Vegas that's
why you [__] hate Vegas yeah
I've seen every corner of that place and
in conclusion it's a bit of a [__]
sorry Vegas fans but it's all coming out
it's all coming out now like I would not
you would not you would not catch me
living there that's because you don't
gamble so no I don't I don't gamble I
don't really care about that there's a
couple like there's a couple of great
restaurants there that I'll [__] love
to go back to every time I go back to
Vegas but other than that
it's just like whatever you know I'd
rather be somewhere else in the US yeah
I mean I I think Vegas was really really
fun when we went there on tour but I
think that's just because you're there
with the boys yeah holiday yeah you know
it's a completely different experience
we've talked about Vegas in the daytime
and that was like I never knew a city
could look so [__] different yeah
look who I beat oh you beat Sasuke
Sasuke
rating was higher yeah I've been well
playing after I've drank almost yeah and
uh I I haven't played in ages and I
throw a lot this is the most
disorganized trash in this episode we're
just talking about a long distance
meanwhile our host is playing chess club
Sasuke after a bottle and a half of wine
bro
the dog [__] right now of course you did
I had zero mistakes zero inaccuracy zero
blunders one great move thank you
chess.com thank you
second than the chess special well by
the time this is out I I will have also
wiped out Paul Champs and lost miserably
but at least I had fun that's good do
you think I'm gonna do well for that
we're gonna age this episode [__] no I
haven't played chess in [__] forever
but I'm playing against saikuno and
Jarvis and I think they're even worse
so that's easy
I can't wait for this I think sakuna was
200 and Jarvis was like are you serious
I think yeah and I think actually I
think Java's pretty good I think John's
like you're on [__] Jarvis's podcast
weren't you yeah I found out the other
day what did you found out like I hit it
it just ran it just randomly you found
it
well first of all first of all uh I
heard you went on another podcast
this is like this is like when you're in
a married relationship for like 10 years
and you're like what were you doing
around like girl's house the other day
let me [__] finish
first of all two other boys first of all
first of all I want to apologize to
Jarvis I didn't even know you had a
podcast
second of all you didn't tell us what do
you mean you didn't need to tell us
everything I need to know everything
you're doing drive you so much [__] I
know tell me everything you're doing
you're on the Jarvis podcast and I've
randomly found it I was like oh [__] he
was on the Jarvis podcast yeah Jarvis is
uh it's pretty dope
why didn't you tell us we need to know
everything that you're doing
what you're doing give me your schedule
right now I need to know everything
you're doing uh
hold on
what you're standing up another chess
game I'm just one yeah
um I remember I was uh so I met I met
driver said um Jarvis Jordan at chess
boxing yeah and Jarvis who I'd obviously
I've seen his videos before yeah I I
didn't know if you know who's with the
Creator you never want to if wow with a
credit you never want to assume they
they know of you it's kind of it's we
it's kind of weird if you do and then
they don't and she's usually assume they
have no idea who you are which is a good
way of doing it and you talk to like a
normal human being yeah but I knew of
Jarvis and then uh Jordan because I'd
watch their stuff before I thought they
were very funny
um and I speak to Jarvis and Jarvis just
started geeking out in this Irish bar in
LA about even Galleon to me and I was
like dude I know two guys who would love
to be here right now but not me I don't
give a [__] when are we getting jobs on
the podcast
comes to Japan bro a really nice guy and
then Jordan who I'd also seen from the
videos who I met that night as well and
I was like Jordan where the [__] are you
from in the UK because you sound so posh
uh he was like I'm from yada yada area I
was like yeah you [__] Posh boy uh
and he stands up smoking I'm so jealous
one tenth as eloquent as he does yeah
and they're both so funny uh they're
really nice guys as well and he's making
bomb lattes he was making the whole
latte art by himself oh [__] it's crazy
you went hard damn I I let the machine
do it there's no artwork it's just it
pours but I like that though I don't
need I don't need artwork but it was
nice that someone else made the artwork
for me what kind of artwork was it
you've seen the classic the like hot the
plant thing that everyone does the leaf
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey not to
knock him down he's still doing it I
don't do that [__] that's just hard as
[__] I've tried doing it and I've
[__] failed at it yeah I mean that's
why people get paid for that [__] yeah
that's why buying his own beans pressing
his own bees with the kids I was like it
was like it was amazing watching him do
it oh yeah I do not have ruined like my
previous apartment because of the coffee
machine we got like an espresso machine
this was before like the Nespresso yeah
well like let's try getting an espresso
machine
and I was just like espresso uh espresso
espresso I can't stop saying Expressions
I don't know what happened to your
childhood because he's fast as [__] boys
Express I was maybe dropped on the head
you know
training actually yeah and that's when I
started like anime actually oh no
um we bought like it was the right
choice we bought an espresso machine uh
like
uh the cheapest one we could find which
obviously had no automation to it as
well so you needed to know what you were
doing I mean I think those benefits to
not being automated yeah that's a lot of
I'm just lazy and I don't want to deal
with it I'm sure there is
um but I learned what those benefits
were uh when I tried to make my first
espresso uh and espresso espresso also
we Gaslight you one time you said
perspirate or something yeah I found out
it's a real word yeah you're wrong yeah
sorry I guess yeah basically like I
tried making my first and then I you
know I was like okay I can follow the
YouTube tutorial put it in I thought I
locked it didn't properly lock so what I
get was high pressure coffee beans
spewing [__] everywhere high
temperature and it stains my white walls
like for like ever and I'm like oh I
should not be allowed near this thing
look at hilarious George
James Hoffman the guy who like talks in
a very
so the coffee beans I know that name
actually you know there's the correct
amount of grams coffee cup before you I
meant to put it I love watching him
because he talked about coffee like it's
a science it's very impressive I imagine
it's like Tom Scott if he got into
coffee
um is very interesting and I I like to
think that I care when I watch but I
really don't I like the machine they
press the one button but I I appreciate
that he cares a lot about it yeah and
that there is a difference I just don't
know yeah he must drink an ungodly
amount of coffee I wish I was him
discuss
reading topic before we change I cannot
remember what we were talking about we
were talking about online relationships
oh yeah and we just said about Joey what
about you guys usually yourself I I did
talk about myself okay
how it's become outdated what about you
have you ever been on a long distance
uh have I ever been a longer yeah I have
when I was like 18. okay yeah
like did it end before you yeah IRS
[__] didn't because I was 18. I have
no goddamn money and uh
uh voice acting oh [__] okay yeah and it
didn't work out well uh and so
uh I was like I'm over this long
distance thing uh so I was over it if I
can't smell you it's game over small
game no game so I but then I uh
I had like uh how many less shoes they
have with that one I had a few and then
like one of them I did Show online and I
pretty much was like what's the [__]
point of showing this online I was like
I got there's no point of talking about
it or whatever because
it when we broke up people were like oh
you're still with that person's like no
no I'm not why do I put myself in a
situation where I could even be put in
there I didn't even know anyway why do I
care if some [__] Steve 81 cares if
I'm in a relationship or not I don't
give a [__] this must be before
yeah yeah how did you guys know I was
dating Sydney
what do you mean I was pretty [__]
obvious wait what the [__] what do you
mean no like you sound like a paranoia
guy like okay
I'm I'm a bit I'm a bit drunk uh I'm
trying to remember when when I found out
about you yeah and this was roughly
around the time where you hit me up yeah
it was like a little bit before then
that I looked into you and then I saw
that you were going out with this girl
called Sydney and I was like Oh okay
that's cool like how did you know that
was it a Wiki or oh [__] I actually
don't know how I knew yeah yeah I'm I'm
trying to think and I'm like when did
you first announce or we never announced
it
yeah no no no no this is
oh [__] okay okay
so you knew we were dating beforehand
right yeah how like I don't know
no actually I think the day I found out
was the day we met up by RL
because Sydney came along yes she did
and then we went to the Izakaya and
karaoke no you you you need to have
known that because I that like I tweeted
you being like hey like I get that
you're in a long distance relationship I
can relate I was also in a long distance
relationship you must have already knew
that before because you replied to
Sydney's tweet as well hold on I hate to
interrupt but our host just left uh that
doesn't matter right now no no I think I
I think I found out because
of when we were having that DM
interaction of like you saying like hey
yeah me you must have said something
along the lines like me and my partner
in Japan right now there's something
along those lines and so I was like oh
okay you have a partner and then when we
met IRL and then I met Sydney and I was
just like oh okay this must be your
partner and then it was just kind of
natural like I think there was a part of
me where I was like this guy can't be
single
he's got too much Wrist
all right genuinely anyone who's
watching this please answer my question
for me because I genuinely don't know
when it became public that like me and
the [__] up yeah
like I generally don't know when it
happened or how it happened mentioned it
in the DM conversation we had before I
feel like I just knew before I met you
though yeah I I just knew I just because
like I never like I was thinking about
it wasn't hearing your story I was like
I've never made an official announcement
that hey me and Sid snap are dating
um well that's because at that point Sid
snap wasn't even like fully established
at that point right like she had made a
couple of videos sure but like she kind
of took like a big break in between
right yeah I mean she did a lot of voice
acting a lot of like online communities
yeah yeah that's how she like made her
name and that's like how we met as well
yeah but like I can't remember and ever
a point where we kind of just announced
that we were dating or anything
like thinking back I'm like oh everyone
just knows it's just like everyone knew
and there was not a point where people
didn't know I was like to be fair that's
probably the easiest coming from someone
who had to make a whole [__] video
around it to be like by the way if you
didn't catch all the signs Aki and I are
dating wait
and there were a lot of people I
remember when I released that video that
was just like your [__] way yeah I
guess there's some people who weren't
invested yeah like you know you know
like on YouTube analytics there's like
the whole thing of like what percentage
of males versus what percentage of
females are talking about this yeah like
it went before I came out about Akio
before Aki and I even like met each
other when we were still in a long
distance I remember I think like my
split was like 50 50 perfectly it was
like 50 male 50 female the most I did
for talking about a [__] anime yeah
yeah I was shocked and I was like who
are these 50 female and then after I
came out or you sound like you want to
find him who all don't exist tell me
where they are women who love anime
don't exist and then the moment I came
out what about Aki I think it dropped to
like 80 20. which in which way male to
female
like my female audience just was just
like all right I'm done and then just
[__] left and then all the dudes were
like my man let's go and then it's been
80 20 ever since so do you have shout
out to the 20 women unrelated to the
Tropic of what you're talking about do
you have any videos or any piece of
media or anything you've regretted
making online
uh yeah really planning like what
um is there anything you wish you didn't
look into or anything you made that you
were like how should I make time like
looking back I wish I could have told
myself not to do it I wish I never did
that [__] L versus loose rap battle
why we would never met if we didn't do
that no because like that set you on a
path to be here today Joey on the trash
taste podcast I feel you and I would
have met some other fashion either way
you know because that Community was
already so small but like I look I
actually recently and like and by
recently I mean like within this year
actually watched that video again
um because you know why do you regret it
because I hit 10 years this year right
and I was just like I'm gonna you know
spend a day to just kind of look back
and reflect on where I've been to kind
of like you know do the 10-year video
which I did
and I and I stumble upon the L versus
Lush video and I was just like holy [__]
this is cringe like yeah that's okay
though but you use regret it why do you
regret it I I just like you wish you
didn't make it yeah I I you you know
what I wish I I wish I had made that
video better well yeah I always wish
that yeah is it like a con like is there
something you've made where you're like
I don't want any iteration of this to
exist I wish I didn't make it
it's hard because I've out of the three
of us I've definitely made the most
amount of videos yeah that's because you
did daily I did daily upload I have like
1200 videos I wish you didn't play
nekapore or something no I I don't again
I don't throw it out I don't regret
nicoparo or the Corpse Party era because
like yeah
how about you gone anything you regret
making or you all of it you feel like eh
about yeah yeah I haven't I haven't made
that many videos
I have one video that I actually took
down just because of how painful it was
it was really early on in my career I
think I was like maybe a year or two
into this
um and I did a video where I was
absolutely shit-faced like I was like
seven or eight beers down right and I
decided my dumb ass drunk brain decided
hey it'd be a really good idea if you
filmed yourself right now and I did this
like three minute Vlog where I'm just
like in this app absolutely drunken mess
I didn't have my shirt on for some
reason so I was just like so it does so
there were Parts yeah so they were
passed in the video where I'm just like
zooming into my nipples and I'm just
like wait you got drunk
made this video and then edited it yeah
I like it I like while strong yeah I
remember vividly I I came back off I
came back from a full day of uni I
recorded like a bunch of like this video
about nothing it was just I think it was
just called I am drunk
just like me
like 7
after I've recorded like a couple of
episodes like nickel power or some RPG
making game or whatever I used to do and
it was just on my phone and I'm just
like recording this three minute [__]
rant about like me being drunk and I
uploaded it as a vlog on my main Channel
with the comments receptive uh I don't
remember to be honest I hope I didn't
scar anyone doing that but like I I took
it down a couple of years later I left
it up there because I completely
forgotten about it and then I think Aki
was the one that mentioned being like oh
I love that video where you're just like
drunk as [__] for three minutes
and then I was like what are you talking
about and then I looked back on my
channel those are the best videos yeah I
looked back on the channel
it's just like I am deleting that
I've gotten to the point now where I've
been making so much stuff for so long
that you could show me video from six
years ago and I'll have no memory of
making it
um I
like cannot remember like half the
things I say on trash days it's like
becoming now I genuinely can't remember
anything well I don't remember what I
said I remember we used to we used to
watch we used to we used to all I'm
slouching like crazy don't don't worry
about it I'm we used to watch all the
episodes we'd all go through them yeah
and review them and then we realized
hold on this is insane I can't watch me
talk about [__] that I talked about
every week [__] two hours
so stop watching what was the last
episode you fully watched all the way
through
uh maybe the Pete one
yeah I mean that was a good video that
was a good episode I mean pizza's so
[__] I'm not I'm not okay not
including guest episodes oh like like
just us like two plus years yeah right
because I feel that like when we talk
it's like ingrained in my memory like I
don't need to watch it again I I
remember like because I'll also remember
stuff that I said that I'm like
and I'd be like was it was it as bad as
I remember it being they'd be like nah
I'm like okay good yeah because I I I
have that like every week I have that
enjoyment of like a news I don't know
what the [__] we're talking and you
trash this episode goes up and I'm like
I don't remember the what the [__] I
said I skimmed through for like the
first 30 minutes and I'm just like damn
I'm about to get [__] flame for this
[__]
all right
have you out in a moment where you set a
take on trash taste and you're like
oh this is gonna like cause all the time
all the time
but also like I realized
I felt like enlightened when I stopped
when I would was willing to say those
takes and be like I don't care about the
aftermath yeah I felt like a power and I
kind of get it a little bit about these
like almost like how these scumbag
YouTubers stay around forever yeah
because they just don't care no yeah
like they see all these comments that
are negative and they just like you it's
so easy to to just get to that point
like I actually just don't care dude
yeah like thousands of people hate me
yeah and I don't give a [__] dude the
moment the moment I finally said on a
trash day episode that I Think Jesus
kaisen is made
okay okay
can I
can I I remember one time I was watching
a video that was Acky and she was like
she was talking about a Ghibli movie she
didn't like yeah and she blurred the
movie that she said that she didn't like
wait which one it was My Neighbor Totoro
because I asked her afterwards I was
like what what was the movie that she
didn't like and she bleeped what she
said because she was so afraid oh that
people would be so I remember that it
was so angry at home saying that she
didn't like my my favorite meanwhile
said like multiple times like and then
we look back at him like how dumb were
all of us to think that you couldn't be
like I don't like yeah no I I okay
concerning that video I specifically
remember telling being like what the
[__] who the [__] is an opinion yeah
it's an opinion there's a lot of people
who don't like my avatar for multiple
reasons as a fan of my neighbor tutorial
and someone who grew up with it I don't
give a [__] like if you don't like it
that's completely understandable
everybody's still up it must be still up
of her believing it probably I want to
see it it's a very old video yeah okay I
should remember this conversation with
that kid I was like I don't
that was that was during the period
where it was like we didn't know the I
guess the boundaries upon which you
could yeah exactly yeah exactly like
popular media I mean like okay so like I
think there's some merits like worrying
about that like I'm I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be real yeah as someone who's
talked about like anime for like [__]
10 plus years have you
yeah like okay so negativity on the like
on the online space especially when it
comes like talking about media you get
like
you got like two three passes right
before people before like yeah I
actually agree with this genuinely
genuinely negative like if you talk
negative about something in terms of
like if you're like a big reviewer you
get two three passes both before people
are like this guy just changes
everything yeah they're right yeah they
just write you off right I think also in
a in like a small drama perspective as
well I've noticed that you can do two
little [__] ups but let me do too many
little [__] ups people are like I just
got a bad feeling about him yeah you
know what I mean and then then you kind
of lose a lot of uh trust with people
concerning concerning the first part
when it comes to like giving opinions on
[__] that is not widely accepted that's
my [__] life yeah I mean in one video
saying that uh maybe it's on online bad
now I became a combini wine I recognize
yeah it is this is the cheap one yeah
sort of online and the same with me for
like I realized I was like man people
give a [__] about this [__] when I yeah
when I spoke about 86 being [__]
boring yeah and
I I genuinely like uh one of the things
I've done or like how I've shifted my
channel like remember the [__]
Angry Video Game Nerd guy with the
glasses kind of days away
yeah I mean like it was there was a
period of the internet where people
thought it was really really cool to
hate on [__] and then it suddenly just
became like uncool overnight because
people just got tired well it's weird
because the YouTube it is cool but
Twitter it's not uh sorry YouTube it
isn't cool and Twitter it is cool so
it's kind of it's whatever you want to
go I mean it's I feel like you say it's
on
it's under
I no it's cool on Twitter yeah
it's like uh
uh I don't know it was like back in the
day when people just call out YouTubers
for whatever reason and now I feel like
YouTubers have gotten to the point where
we're all trying to just make a [__]
job out of this we'll just survive yeah
and so the the when you like I want to
call this person why they're a piece of
[__] it's like okay but like
what's that gonna do like yeah you look
like the [__] yeah the other one
aggressing yeah and so it's like even if
there are scumbag YouTubers out there
I think a lot of people aren't [__]
pushing or trying to expose people
anymore because it's like it's kind of
like not much benefit to doing it
because everyone's just trying to make a
business it's like you know I'm sure
it's like [__] way back in the day
when you sabotage your [__]
competitor and pizza making and you're
like actually just works out better if
everyone just likes Pizza more uh let's
just not [__] each other over sure yeah
I mean like it's it's kind of like
people just get tired like of someone
who's just really negative and that's
why I realized oh that's pungent
oh I'm sorry this is combini wine now
yes I've got a last Good carry on Karen
yeah so like I remember like I I made
like a conscious decision with my
content yeah to like shift it to you too
yeah to like Okay so
I I know I've gotten like a lot of
comments being like Oh God likes
everything God never shits on a show and
I'm just like I there are shows that are
popular that I don't like I just choose
not to like highlight them what do you
get out of shooting on a show yeah yeah
exactly you lose a bit of your audience
yeah you know you know the problem is
that video was is gonna blow up because
a lot of people are going to be like yo
he hates on the show he dunks on a show
and you get like you should make a
one-piece video shooting on the one
piece fans they'll Crush
you basically just described my entire
career until a couple of years ago yeah
because here's here's the thing you get
like two or three and like people are
with you and then I've noticed after
like a few too many shows that you hate
on even if you're like genuinely like
have points they'll be like this is just
a negative person yeah I don't wanna I
think I think for the majority of people
who like kind of know me on a surface
level I'm just known as the guy who's
like he hates sword online he thinks
school days is a 10 out of ten you do
make a lot of video shooting on it no
I'm made one did you really I literally
hide my head I thought that you made
something this is the thing so many
people think I am like the I hate so
online guy I made one video and it was a
parody
of like my character Vegeta review 69
yeah if you remember you're an OG of
like him like making this like satirical
parody on saying like it's the best
anime ever even though I'm shooting on
it and that one video has like labeled
me as like he's the guy that hates saw
online I'm like wait wait okay but first
of all I've never heard anyone say this
about you no dude so many people say
that about me it's just a case of like
you see it the most because you're the
guy because I don't see this man I've
never seen this appear I don't know but
like I've seen this opinion yeah oh okay
yeah a lot I'm not trying to Gaslight
you no no I get it like a lot of people
I want to be the guy that hates oceanoko
it's cringe
the moment I say like in one video I'm
like yeah I think uh school days was
kind of brilliant
immediately I'm the guy that's like oh
he thinks school days is a 10 out of 10
and everyone knows it's a [__] anime so
here's opinions are invalid because he
doesn't watch anime anymore and it's
just and I'm just like okay yeah sure
like take away all of my opinions from
the past like 10 plus years of like
watching anime
yeah I mean I mean that's it's it's like
I constantly have to bot
a bottle uh because you have to battle
between you know stuff that let's say I
watch a show and I don't like it I can't
have to battle between like how much do
I highlight to show that I was not a fan
of versus like I've taken like the
content I never noticed you had been
positive throughout your videos but now
it makes a lot of sense yeah I mean like
I'm not POS like that doesn't mean God
doesn't in a smile yeah that doesn't
mean I hide that doesn't mean I like
everything but you don't [__] on it no
no no no no like here's the thing here's
the thing exception's dog whatever yes I
I just highlight the stuff that I like
you know I don't like I don't [__] on
the stuff that I don't like like it's
not that I'm afraid of [__] on it I
just want more like it's it's like it's
like a kind of like a shift to be like I
just want more coverage on the stuff
that I do like that makes sense rather
than just covering
yeah yeah you you did it in a smart way
where like you decided to not go against
the north to to go against the norm
rather and just cover stuff that you are
actually passionate about you actually
enjoyed whereas during that same period
in the like mid to late 2010s uh
especially in the energy Community it
was like almost a trend to be like hey
let's oh that was a trend on YouTube
yeah right like let's watch your movie
sing and dissect on why it [__] sucks
and you know I admit I I'm fully I was
fully involved in that movement and you
know in a lot of respects I got big
because of that I mean it's easier to
and you know there's I mean you can look
at this from the the game reviewers you
know because some game reviews do top 10
games a year top 10 worst games of the
year you'd always see the worst games of
the year one would do so much better of
course it does makes people just love
negativity negative like here's the
thing like I don't want to hear someone
tell me about what the best game was I
know what the best game yeah exactly I
mean like it's like negative minions is
like the easy way to get views yeah
which is why I always just like not that
I was like I'm against easy views I'm
just like I just want to focus on the
things that I do [__] like because my
life is happier if I do so I'm like like
here's a big tell about if I don't like
something or if I don't like a show I
just don't talk about it like that
that's like the biggest deal see I just
don't talk about it this man this man
built it
because you've you've had the
fortunate nature of starting very early
yeah being able to build an audience and
a reputation for being reliable and now
you're at that point I think if somebody
had started again from Gone Gone style
today yeah I think they'd struggle that
is yeah that is scripted content that's
not trash taste trash days are I will
talk about [__] yeah I mean would you
agree that if Gartner started today
doing a similar style it would be a lot
tougher
I don't think so
um I think if I started today I would go
for a different approach a different
style yeah uh yeah it's okay so okay
yeah like to me in terms of like making
content you always got to make something
that someone isn't already doing better
and the problem if I started today is
I'm already making my content right so
the only enemy is me not the only enemy
is me like I I'm I've done a I've done a
lot uh I've done a lot I've put many
years making like my style of content so
if I started again I'd probably make a
completely different style account right
still anime but just a different story
do you think it's I'm sorry no I was
just asking like what how would it be
different okay so if I started now I'd
probably be making stuff on more like
Theory and like kind of like that Styler
content
everyone does that power scale don't do
that not power scale I I would okay
here's the thing here's like here's what
I would do a lot of people are making
Theory kinds of content but I would try
to find a way that to make that kind of
content that
has not like is not like totally
saturated you know because I love that
yeah there is a lot of that kind of like
Theory kind of content and that's very
very popular right now
um I feel like there is a kind of like
Gap to be like here is some really I I
don't want to give everything away in
case I I mean you could honestly do that
now
I have a question in every single
YouTube genre there are multiple people
who are crushing it and doing well yeah
yeah why does it feel like in anime
you have been the guy and there's not
been much else happening like there are
some YouTubers anime doesn't make money
there are some other big YouTubers who
talk about anime they definitely are but
there's no one I feel that has been at
your level and I feel like that's super
red okay YouTube yeah like I I will
answer this because like I know this now
that I've like met other YouTubers in my
um my field or other like massive
YouTubers yeah like considering like
looking at this from a business
perspective it's terrible I as a huge as
a purely anime YouTuber and uh I'm
making like [__] crumbs compared to
YouTubers My Level my subscriber my free
account yeah so if I'm like the top
anime YouTuber what does that what does
that mean about incentive to grow yeah
what does that say about a lot of people
trying to like find their footing in my
field you know yeah I mean I think a lot
of talents of people who covered anime
initially so
pivoted yeah out of it like John and you
oh yeah you yeah
uh you know I think uh a lot of creators
realized early on that like I can't just
be a bad anime yeah
um and so I mean like John I think is a
prime example of that John is such a
talented Storyteller super output yeah
so good at making videos so good Italian
story I I think it's the one of the best
things that ever happened is that on
YouTube you just just stopped talking
about anime as much yeah because I love
his videos I think he makes great videos
about stuff he just likes even if I
don't care about his wrestling videos
sometimes sorry John I still watch him I
still watch his wrestling videos yeah
[__] John I don't give a [__] about
wrestling but John I don't either until
I watch the video and I'm like okay I
don't care now yeah and so I I think he
does a great job and I I think yeah I
think a lot of anime YouTubers realize
early on or at some point they're like
hold on I can take everything I've
learned from this yeah and just apply it
to a more general purpose yeah and
probably succeed a little bit yeah well
that's that's exactly what I did like I
I kind of got to the point where I I for
one personally was kind of getting like
bored of making anime content because of
how repetitive it was and kind of how in
like like non-innovative it was uh you
know because there's only so many like
creative ways that you can make and like
pure anime content right and obviously
there are people like God and you know
other people who can still do content
like that and it'd be [__] amazing
but me personally I realized like okay I
do like this whole anime thing but at
the same time there are also other
elements especially about Japanese
culture that I have a massive passion
for and I want to explore those a little
bit you're also native and Japanese it's
such a waste to be just talking about
anime all the time exactly and that's
why I like to be covering more yeah
stuff that takes advantage of your
ability exactly and that's why like you
know I've been doing more of those like
interview videos and like yeah kind of
covering Japanese news and like kind of
using that skill that I never was aware
of that I had to be I was in my
advantage I would kill for the your
ability in Japanese I think I'll be able
to make such different videos but yeah
I'll never ever even if I got fluent
it's like I'd still never be the same
level that would allow me to open up
those doors and at the same age
that would make it interesting but you
know I think uh I think one thing that
we've done really well is that we go for
different angles into this yeah if you
never use the same topic
more Wells content
there's not a demand there's no one
cares I think I think honestly there's
ways I could do it yeah there's some
videos there's some angles I could
explore yeah okay you say that but on my
second Channel like a couple of months
ago I made a video just as a test of top
10 Australian uh musical bands that are
underrated in my opinion that video at
20 000 views
no I think I think that there's a way I
could tell a story in a way but it would
have to be so well done yeah yeah and I
have to put so much work into it that it
it like
you kind of forget that when you live
somewhere you're like okay I kind of
have to make content around this area
and if I want to expand new content in
other countries
that's a huge commitment yeah especially
if we're talking about the level of
quality we need to be able to make
something that people would actually
watch yeah absolutely like I don't know
there's always some fun videos there
must be some cool content like I I I
watch videos about Farm dudes being a
farmer like and I like that I think it's
fun yeah right but like what would I add
by doing that nothing I need to make
more of an in-depth story if it
warranted me going out there and even
then it's like okay what am I what would
I talk about I don't know I I feel like
it's cool if you can show off you know
some of the [__] culture that you
grew up in and like you have the
opportunity it's tough you know it's
tough but I would like to I would
personally like yeah I mean you would
but I think a lot of people wouldn't
it's not Sensational enough for YouTube
It's the vocal minority right but I I
knew right away when I was getting into
YouTube and I started making some
especially enough money to start looking
at this like okay I can I can I can
maybe at some point pay rent soon that's
when I kind of decided I was like I
gotta change it up I gotta figure out
how to yeah good thing you're not the
best you can go anymore I wouldn't be
here
but like you know one thing that I've
always had a lot of
um conversations with a lot of YouTubers
is when they want to change up their
content they want results like that yeah
they want it they want to change they
want it to be done yeah I don't know you
do they took me like a year and a half
two years it doesn't happen the
transition off there yeah like that's
not that's not a quick process like
you've given if you want to gain an
audience whilst also keeping the
audience you have happy you can say [__]
it to your audience you can be like [__]
them I'm gonna make new stuff I'll find
a new audience you can do that and
that's a legit strategy but you've got
to be okay with bombing for a while yeah
but it can't work and creators have done
it but I was more so concerned and I
think a lot of creators are there like I
want to keep the numbers going but
transition it and that took like two
years of making weird [__] that was very
in between and still including Sebastian
content but trying to you know get
people to yeah experimental stuff like
let's watch let's watch me
um voice act an anime character while
wearing that character's costume and
playing a game that requires me to
control the volume yeah that's a video
idea I had and I made and I don't know
why but I think it did okay at the time
I think it for me weirdly the turning
point where it really kicked off uh was
the cosplay videos remember those videos
I used to do yeah I remember those I
remember those those videos used to
crush and I this is the first time I
ever had videos that really did really
well yeah it was just me putting on dumb
[__] costumes and I was like okay
here we go this is like finally I found
a series yeah that uses anime in a
creative way without relying on any uh
me actually getting into the IP yeah and
that really like allowed me to make
these other videos that really did well
and that was kind of what changed
everything for me
um I mean I guess I haven't really
stopped them but I kind of felt like
they were done I just felt like it was
over like I felt like there was nothing
more I could do and anything else I
would do was kind of arbitrary to this I
I bought a bunch more so I have more
yeah from like a year ago so I couldn't
wear them I think they're like chainsaw
man stuff yeah and I could wear it and
it could work and it could be a funny
video but I just I don't know I I just
feel like it kind of run its course I
don't know but I I feel like over that
year your standards of what is suitable
for the main channel is definitely you
say that but I'm I'm just bashing out
crying games so like who's really but
the problem is the cranking videos Crash
people love them yeah they do really
well and also the easiest part is that
they're easy to film
um because a lot of the videos that we
do with like Tahoe or we do whatever
it's like we just take too long yeah it
takes so long to make and the cranking
videos I can call up the the places that
I filmed that I'd be like hey can I come
film and they're like yeah so it's good
it's really easy it's a great way to do
more collaboration because I missed
doing collaboration yeah uh and so it's
kind of like all right well I guess I'm
I'm the crane game guy now yeah that's
why I like doing it it's fun it's chill
yeah and it works man I care about live
streaming and stuff more which is like
YouTube which is so weird because it's
like I had I spent like seven years of
my life dedicated to this one idea and
this one thing and this one concept and
then I'm like yeah actually you know
what [__] it from change
hey man if if that if that satisfies you
then I I say go creatively I think it's
better and I think the one thing that I
I like most about making live content
um and I maybe you guys have starting to
appreciate this more is that when you're
done you turn the stream off you're done
yeah that's it it's over I mean that's
just me doing trash taste and every
other kind of content I have grown very
jealous for you guys to be able to like
turn on the camera uh go all like go to
a film session and uh like having like a
block in your calendar that is like okay
after after the calendar after the
camera's off I'm done yeah I mean
there's that obviously but I I was
really getting tired of the
post-production aspect of it oh yeah and
having to deal with
if we filmed somewhere you know maybe
they want to have a look at the video
and they want to change a ton of things
that are really mind you and don't
matter but they care about it for some
reason yeah and then you know you're
like okay well that's why I don't do
videos that warranty yeah bro like it's
tough I you know I feel that I was just
getting really burnt out with the
post-production in Japan and having to
go through the videos yeah and make them
good and I just didn't have a talent for
it like I would talk to Chris and
Christian Science be like man that video
was bad and I was like I know it's bad
but I don't know how the [__] to make it
better I'm [__] at this I this video was
tough and I think I would need to be
better at what I do and I think I've
gotten a lot better now but yeah I was
really like not good at it for a very
long time and I still think I'm good but
I'm getting better and I just don't
enjoy it as much so I just I get so much
more excited about an idea when it's
live yeah so I I just kind of lean
towards that now yeah I mean your
personality is definitely like garnered
towards that like for me I've really
really [__] missed scripted content
after I've been doing like live streams
and like second Channel and trash days
and stuff you can tell such different
stories yeah but then I'm like I sit
down and like I what I don't miss is
waking up some days and I'm like I'm
gonna get x amount of words done in my
scripts and you wake up and you get the
sentence done and you're like
[__] today was a write-off you know
today today was right off right because
like some days you wake up and you're
like I am writing like a [__] machine
and sometimes you wake up and you're
like I cannot think of anything that's
what I like about streaming right like
even if it's like that's what I like
about it as well I'll do a 13-hour
stream and I'll feel like [__] I went
through the [__] Gauntlet but at
least I could have like I didn't [__]
procrastinate a day away yeah which I
easily could do when I was a YouTuber
mainly yeah you know because the one
benefit I liked is that I used to upload
weekly but I used to be able to make
all right I used to be able to make like
a month worth of videos and like I
really wanted to I could make it like a
week and a half oh no like some serious
grinding yeah then I kind of disappear
and no one knew yeah I kind of like that
but also I realized that I was also
creatively I was not improving as a
Creator because I wasn't taking that
time to really focus on how to uh
improve my content and how to become a
better Creator yeah like I've definitely
felt that with my second Channel where
I'm like I am a month and a half ahead
and I've done that just by being live
and I'm like it feels good to be to shut
off the stream and really be like my job
is done but then I kind of miss I I
cried for a long time I've missed the
scripted content and I was like making
different kinds of content and I'm like
I can do this for a certain amount of
time
after a while I'm like my mind goes to
like mush and I'm like I can't do this
well every year I get a head a little
bit on the second Channel yeah I
normally stream more than I
would do and I like to stream content
stuff and we get ahead on the second
Channel I'm like mood in December
load every day every other day I was
like are you sure I'm like let's do it
let's get the ad rev should we upload
and casino I also want you know and it's
a lot of work but I also yeah uh I want
because we we share the money so I
wanted I want to move down to these boys
to get paid well as well I was like
let's just go ham in December let's go
crazy then we end up in January with
like one video he's like oh Connor um we
need more videos right now and I'm like
oh I'm away for two weeks I'm like ah
I'll think of something it was
scrambling but it's nice because you're
never too far behind the videos oh I
gotta asked
how did you guys learn how to like
manage people
because like I've I've realized like
because I work closely with my editor
Adam and a lot of other people like my
my like corporate experience was like so
[__] valuable for me to be like okay
there's a structured like system to like
manage someone and yeah kind of like I
communicate I think for me because I've
hired a lot of people now doing various
stuff
um
I think I think we're at that point now
with work in general where
I know what I need to what I need them
to do for it to make sense for me to
keep hiring them yeah right so I have a
set amount of things I need them to do
and if they do it I don't give a [__] if
they slack off for 10 hours or they
don't work one week yeah as long as in
that month everything I care about that
gets done gets done yeah and so you know
I I'm just Frank with that I I tell a
lot of my employees that I work with I'm
like hey I don't give a [__] what you do
as long as what I ask you to do gets
done and I'll never be anti-japanese
sentiment pretty much
you can go and play TFT or OSU for 12
hours a day yeah as long as in those you
you cram in those four hours and you get
the thing done and it's done well yeah
um and so I'm I'm pretty chill like I'm
I whether it's a good or a bad thing I I
don't know I think it works well with
some people it doesn't work well with
others yeah because I I can't be there
to like I don't have a manager who's
working with me it's just me I hire
people and I work with them because I
like to have that relationship
um but I I I'm I don't have the ability
to be Hands-On every single day and I'm
not going to have a meeting every week
like I'm just like I'll leave you to it
you do your thing here's what I'm going
to ask for and I'll keep spamming you
about stuff yeah uh and yeah and then it
normally works out and I think just
having that kind of relationship where
you both trust each other is very
important takes a while to get there but
once you get it it's invaluable like
that's worth more than anything I think
yeah in terms of you know it's like hey
I got you you got me uh we're good
totally agree yeah yeah I mean you
started you were a [__] company man
look at you yo Mansi big boy big boy I I
probably sound really condescending
right now what a widow baby boys
being adult is realizing you need help
and what that means
uh figuring out how to integrate that
yeah I think I think for me like doing
the whole like clothing company thing
like I think I got very lucky with
people who I'm surrounded with in terms
of like the company because like I I
think it's a matter of like okay no no I
was about to say like I'm an idiot I
should interrupt you mid-center like a
[__] toddler because I have a thought
carry on I I think it's this whole idea
of like I got very blessed with having
hired and meeting people who are now
responsible for the company who are just
way more competent than I am well yeah
who are like who are like just on top of
this [__] very professional like they're
still like you know I think you hire
good people and you figure out the job
afterwards absolutely like I think it's
a matter of like you know I think it's
it's all about like can do you have the
pulling power to be able to hire people
who are more competent than you I think
that's like the best you're not
competent compared to my like
dude I had nonsense for example my brand
manager and my head designer infinitely
more competent than I am like I I would
just straight up admit that like they
those guys are like everything good
you're seeing out of the nonsense right
now is because of those guys what's the
end goal with nonsense what are you what
are you feeling about end goal is to
just be able to like do you must have
had a vision when you started it right
yeah I mean obviously for me it's just
like you know I'm like my end goal with
nonsense is to get to the point where I
could be walking the streets of wherever
the [__] I am and I will see someone who
walks past me shirt and they don't know
who I am why why is that what you want
because because it's it's it's
I'm going ADHD mode I was just like I
would like to walk the streets of
anywhere and I was like North Korea
but I want to get to the point blank
like for me because like I've been so I
guess like weirdly reliant on like the
whole anime man brand at this point that
like you know as of right now there's a
mixture of one of the branch out but
also have more of a long lasting effect
exactly like I want to get to the point
where like obviously right now because
you know our company is like just a year
old at this point right like we started
in June last year I feel like it's like
two three yeah we only started June last
year right like and so it's a very young
company and obviously the majority of
the people who are buying my clothes are
people who know me or like no trash day
at the point where it's not that yeah I
want to get to the point where it's just
like people who just think the clothes
are [__] cool and I want to wear
those clothes regardless of who it comes
from or what the origins are can wear it
and just get to the point where like
again I could be walking the streets of
anywhere in the world I see someone
wearing a nonsense t-shirt and they no
[__] idea who I am I think that's the
point like I just want to make cool [__]
it regardless of where I currently am
socially standing right like so and you
know obviously like I I also want to
like you know just like make cool [__]
through that company regardless of what
it is
um because I've always had that like you
know dream to do so but like as of right
now at least my short-term goal is to
just like kind of expand the brand out
to the point where you don't necessarily
have to be a fan of me to be able to buy
my clothes yeah yeah that's a good idea
and you know that's very difficult right
now obviously you know kind of branching
out from where you currently are to a
wider audience but we're doing our best
to try and get to that point and
hopefully next couple of years we'll get
to that point yeah you know yeah why do
you sound like yeah yes sorry I was
trying to sorry what what did you
interrupt me on
okay what do you think the end of trash
taste looks like what do you what I
think the end of trash Chase looks like
I think it's one of us get moving on you
think it's we all agree
you have a kid yeah you don't but you
the kid needs money gone you're gonna be
here every goddamn way output okay okay
okay
I say that in like half just because I'm
like to me like the big kind of like
turning point for me yeah is I don't
think I'm gonna stop being friends with
you guys after I have a gift but I'm
like okay guys
I have a priority now and it's not you
guys but like when I have a kid that's
like to me that's like a commitment you
know I I wanna not you can't hang out
okay so you're gonna come to work
everywhere so like that you you must
have gotten the question being like how
long do you see yourself in Japan uh
yeah how long do you see yourself in
Japan and to me that kind of like
the crossroads sorry yes I think at the
moment I think any of us leave Japan
it's going to be I imagine there'll be a
conversation like yeah yeah how do we
keep it going and then like is it worth
continuing how do we end it yeah hold
that thought because I gotta piss okay
well we'll just keep talking yeah we'll
just keep talking keep talking yeah
because like I think it's valid I think
that's it I mean you know I think
pretending like trash taste is going to
be a forever thing is dumb yeah and I
think thinking about it is wise yeah I
mean like trash trash Chase is like a
great thing a fun thing
um like I'm not like I said every show's
got to end yeah let's let's show except
Grace [__] anatomy
and Law and Order which will never end
but at least I wanna I wanna end on a
bang I don't want to whimper into like a
[__] is that the potaku side of you
talking no I wanted potsaku to get even
[__] bigger and it could have which
is which it could have and I will stick
by that to this day but it's great
because I have trash taste now but like
like
to split the [__]
[Laughter]
no I just want to make I just wanted to
make something cool but like no to me
like kid want to have a kid they are
going to be top priority I want them to
have you're not going to want to yeah
you know you know ideally
yeah yeah yeah and as Asian Japan is
yeah as they should be there there's
enough people in the world that have a
kid and treat them like a toy or like
even like a pet like they they treat
like a pet like more like a toy than
like a commitment to like raise this kid
right and I'm like I don't want to be
that parent
um so you know that's like to me when I
decide to have a kid that's going to be
like the commitment uh whether I want to
settle down in Japan wherever I think
Japan is the best place to raise the kid
I'm still like up in the air about but
like they are going to take top priority
yeah I guess that's the question I have
for you too because like I think in my
mind I have a pretty you're gonna be
here forever I'm probably gonna
if you know gaijin's been here for like
decades has proven anything like it's
not impossible for like complete
foreigners to be here for the rest
my ideal scenario is that I've got an
insane boatload of cash and I can live
between the two countries to my Will
Wait UK and Japan yeah like I I I can't
ever see myself that's one question I
wanted to know is that right to you guys
what I I would love to have that thing
of like I fancy being in you know maybe
I live in the UK but I'm like yeah I
fancy two months in Japan I go to my
[__] Mansion I have in Japan I order
Sebastian to come over
you know the ideal is that yeah I'd have
I wouldn't have to care about my having
a [__] house in there and I wanted
them like I just live between the two
like that's I but obviously that's a
stupid amount of money and time and
whatever but you know because I think
even if I leave Japan I think there'll
be a part of me that loves Japan dearly
or want to be here every year okay
here's the question I have what's your
guys's end goal
yeah I haven't got an end goal I just
want to create stuff right now that's
right I just want a crazy stuff and hope
it lasts forever not even forever I
think I think being creative is a
momentary thing I think not everyone
gets to be an artist that gets to
survive generations of course yeah I
think just making stuff that keeps
people happy for a little while is more
than enough
I've reached my end goal you're married
I got married I have given my parents a
stable life which is all I wanted to do
uh that's the end goal for me quitting
my jobs do YouTube so um see that's why
my man is a [__] horse
and you're like I I will not die until I
swim in a pool so I'm not gonna like I'm
not I'm not gonna retire tomorrow but
I'm like
I'm satisfied I but you need to do
something that's that's the thing you
probably have some like you you probably
have some things where you're just like
no I still haven't done that yet yeah
I'd like I have big projects that I
really really want to do that I'm
working on right now but in terms of
like
my end goal and going sounds like
[__] just like what I did this for
originally yeah I reached that and I'm
like very very happy to have done that
so now I'm just like even if the stuff I
do in the future fails I'm like I've
already done what I wanted to do I'm a
very simple man uh which is why I'm just
like I am content which is why
as long as the people around me are
happy no matter what I'll be happy yeah
oh yeah that's that's just me that's the
song that's me being [__] drunk I
mean I saw like a Twitter post it was
like there is no benefit to being a good
human being
um wait who said that I was on Twitter I
was doing really it was doing very well
yeah well yeah I mean technically we're
talking about like how you advance and
manipulate yeah of course there's
nothing inherently beneficial to being
good people but yeah your entire worth
as a human being when you realize hey
how the people feels great yeah being a
part of someone's Journey getting
involved absolutely yeah is easy to be
skeptical uh but I think being
successful means being able to help
those around you and help them
unconditionally and get something very
important absolutely [__] respecting
respect for you for doing all the
[__] charity stuff yeah man [__] I
appreciate it well I mean that was like
that was something that kind of you know
I I wasn't like I consciously decided to
do it I wish I could be benevolent and
be like yeah of course I wanted to do it
yeah you know it just turned out that
the thing's all lined up you know it
kind of I found a good cause you know I
felt I felt like I really wanted to help
mass in that aspect yeah and uh you know
I felt like
you know I think it's safe to say we
we've all three of us have made a good
amount of money like I feel like we're
doing okay like we're good like I
I'm fine monetarily like I don't need to
make x amount of money a month I could
I'm fine for for a good little while I
can't live for the rest of my life but
like in this very moment with the amount
of making I'm good yeah so I was like I
just kind of looked and I was like
it just makes no more sense to do
anything for for me it felt like there
wasn't much sense to do projects that
were full profit Also let's make
something creative maybe make a little
bit of money on the side but let's make
the main focus making money for good
causes yeah yeah because like why the
[__] not yeah like let's absolutely like
I just for me it felt like the right
thing to do and I get it that now for
everyone it doesn't feel that way uh and
I would never press any creators into
doing any charity stuff because like I
feel like if your heart's not it you
shouldn't do it yeah obviously it still
helps voluntarily but like I think if
you really really want to get people
invested yeah and raise money and get
people involved
I think you've got to be your heart's
gonna be in it yeah and I think that was
the problem they had before is that like
I just didn't feel there was a charity
that I really connected with there was a
few that I I like the idea of but I yeah
I mean we all like charity and we all
like the idea of it but let's be real a
lot of us you don't care like a lot of
us aren't connected to it because and I
think rightfully so we all care about
how the [__] we're doing yeah a lot of
us are struggling I think a lot of the
viewers at home are not not doing too
well or you're going through something
and I think it's totally valid to care
about what you're going through and what
you what you're doing uh but I think
when you get to a point financially
where you're very stable you have to
kind of be like all right there's going
more to it there's got to be more to
what I'm doing yeah and there's got to
be a way I can give back yeah and I
think doing that is very important when
you have a platform yeah um I really
really mean that I I mean I totally
agree with you uh I I'd say when I was
younger I would probably you hear about
resno Red Nose Day all these Charities
or whatever it is I would probably be
the type of person that would like that
tweet that you saw and like yeah me too
you know
because they're all merits you do you
will climb a lot faster if you don't
honestly you look at some of some of the
people now that are successful you're
like these are all horrible people what
and what has Society taught us that
horrible people uh climb uh if you want
to be successful you be the loudest and
you be the person who shouts the loudest
yeah and you will get attention and uh
most of the time you'll be successful
and I'm like okay well that's well
that's how Society is like
uh that's that's how Society is like
structured at least right now where the
people who shout loudest get the most
attention and the people get the most
attention normally now make the most
money you know that's not always the
sense but it is I mean more views more
money yeah
you know it's unfortunate that charity
is kind of you know I mean I feel like
almost
I I don't know if this is true but it
feels like credit is do less stuff by
charity now than ever I don't know why I
feel that way I will tell you why
uh because by doing charity but okay
look at someone like Mr Beast for
example yeah okay I I generally think Mr
Beast is doing something positive for
the world but by getting a lot of time
by getting a lot of eyes on you by doing
something positive you are actually
putting yourself at risk that's so funny
because because it's [__] up that even
if you do something like
net positive Goods people will try to
poke holes and people will try to find
like nefarious
he's just doing it for attention yeah
you know he's doing it because he wants
to make himself look like a young person
which you can't deny that there there is
an aspect of that not like there is an
aspect of doing something good gets you
attention
like social yeah so there's all other
celebrities that we feel are very
disingenuous yeah yeah exactly but it
sucks that when you try to do something
good sometimes that gives you more
attention and more eyes on you and more
people criticizing you because you are
trying to do something good for the
world as opposed to doing something for
profit or doing something yeah
I firmly believe that every Creator is
well off
um should be doing charity stuff at
least once a year or something
um
but I I also understand that that motive
yeah like you said you get too big from
doing it yeah what not I think the hard
part is that and I realized this through
myself is that
um it's hard
to really sell a charity to your viewers
if there's not some kind of personal
story there and it kind of sucks but
like you know when you see these these
ads about oh every five seconds a kid
dies or something and we're so
desensitized we are we are so [__]
sensitized and then we you know and and
that was because that was attracted for
a very long time yeah and I imagine it
worked at some point but it doesn't work
anymore because we just don't care like
yeah and I think it's fair to say that's
where we're at yeah and so I think as
creators there needs to be some kind of
personal connection but it's kind of
tough because obviously maybe we're all
young and we don't have these
connections to X charity because we
don't have any experience with them yeah
so I think as a Creator you you need to
almost look for a cause to kind of be
passionate about and get excited about
because I think also your viewership
will also appreciate that you're excited
about raising money for a good call
viewers are very very smart if you do
not care about something they can tell
yeah you got you got you guys are smart
causes me like that dick but like you
know occasionally there'll be a thing
and not not to be like this charity but
this does happen a lot like they'll be
like people like yeah yeah cancer
research you're like okay
yeah all right I get it like that's a
very very very common disease it takes a
lot of lives yeah but I think to a lot
of people that seems almost disingenuous
because it's kind of like you don't have
a personal story and it sucks it has to
be the case but I think for for people
that almost needs to be a personal story
or a connection to sell people on why
you care so much about this I think
almost picking some generic stuff you
know even you know even though like uh
sometimes you see like mental health
stuff it's like oh it's almost too broad
reaching sometimes I think it's kind of
tough because we're in this age now
where you're almost pressured into
caring too much about a subject or a
specific kind of illness yeah um and
I've learned that a lot through through
working with uh with what I've been
doing I've learned that that having that
really specific story has been very very
good for getting people involved and
caring about it which sucks because if
maybe if I cared about it and I didn't
have a personal connection I might not
have been able to sell people this much
right yeah do you know what sucks about
that because I've gone through like this
very similar thing where I'm I wear it's
just like I have you want to do
something I have these certain things
that I care about that has affected my
family and [__] like that yeah but I've
like for example I I've never talked
about it on trash taste because it's
very like personal thing I've never kind
of like you know really talked about it
publicly so I know to like an audience
is just gonna like come out left Fields
yeah right you know and it's just like
it it sucks that when you are doing
something good like charity you need to
prove that you care about this stuff I
mean I think it's because there's so
many disingenuous scenarios yeah yeah
people don't and that's and that's the
[__] issue where there is so many
like bad eggs in the world that try to
take advantage of people try to like
take advantage and do whatever to make
themselves look good that I'm that it's
just made it so much harder to actually
like try to do good in this world holy
[__] we are so drunk because this is a
relative [__] talk right now all
right we're only two and a half bottles
of wine in PTSD uh uh charity okay uh
support your local charities do do the
outro because I need I need to pee okay
support your local charities be a good
person uh respect your elders and uh
[__] them hoes uh hey look at all these
patrons though
so anyway guys I'm gonna call a taxi
look at all these patrons that's [__]
crazy uh if you by the way if you guys
want to see another drunk episode of
trash days then feel free to uh
especially if I can't handle this smash
the like button uh because I'm totally
down for this [__] what are they asking
me Joey the Japanese cab is asking me
questions uh it says
uh yes or no account on
wait
the one can't you can read was a context
yeah don't answer hey if you want to see
more trash days episodes like this hey
fuel well alcoholism by following us on
patreon but patreon.com trash taste also
follow us on Twitter send us some news
on the subredding if you haven't even
face listen to us on Spotify I don't
even know oh Jesus one of us is away the
other one is burping up a storm and uh
we will see you guys in the next episode
of oh [__] oh Jesus Christ all right see
you guys later bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]